Hallo Wissen!
Hallo Ben!
Hallo Akronomisierbar!
Hey!
Wir sind auch da!
Was ist denn hier passiert?
Okay, wir sind nicht in einer ganz normalen Folge
weder Hallo Swift noch Akronomisierbar,
denn wir befinden uns
auf dem Chaos Communication Kongress.
Wir beenden schon die Sätze des
Sandwich, was?
Ja, wir sind auf dem Chaos Communication Congress
in Leipzig. Ende Dezember.
Wir sind zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr. Bei euch muss man das
dazusagen. Ihr braucht ja immer so einen Monat, bis die
von der Straße kommen.
Du darfst niemals sagen, wann wir aufnehmen.
Wir müssen auch jetzt bei wir natürlich noch einen
Zusatz dazu sagen.
Genau, ein Caveat.
Dass wir, zumindest von Seiten von
Harris Swift, beschränkt sich auf
Ben und Vincent, wie ihr gehört habt. Denn Dom ist
leider dieses Jahr nicht dabei.
Hoffen, dass wir ihn dieses Jahr bestechen können.
Genau, wir können uns ja mal kurz vorstellen, denn selbst uns kennt man ja vielleicht bei Akronomisierbar nicht und andersrum.
Deswegen fangen wir jetzt im Uhrzeigersinn an, von mir aus Nummer 12.
So, okay, hallo liebe Akronomisierbar-Hörer.
Das ist Schluss bei der zweiten Keks, das übrigens.
Ach, das hört man überhaupt nicht, die Headseins sind echt hochqualitativ.
Hallo liebe Akronomisierbar-Hörer, wir sind Folge 12 von Akronomisierbar und wir haben zwei Gäste.
Wir machen nämlich ein Joint Venture auf diesem heutigen zweiten Tag des Chaos Communication Kongress 34 C3 in Leipzig.
Und wir haben uns angemeldet bei der Sendezentrale, wo Podcaster auf dem Kongress seit einigen Jahren regelmäßig Folgen aufnehmen können.
Und wir hatten ein bisschen Angst, dass wir wie die letzten Jahre in Hamburg auch noch ein Publikum hier haben.
Aber wir sitzen dieses Mal relativ abgeschlossen an einem runden Tisch, an einer kleinen Ecke bei den Assemblies.
Die winken uns gerade.
An einem Nachbartisch gibt es eine Live-Schalte,
wo die Leute live über Mikrofone bei uns zuhören.
Oh, die Kekse kommen wieder weg.
Du bist jetzt übrigens auf der Aufnahme raus.
Das war Alex.
Wir sitzen hier mitten in den Assemblies.
Das Hintergrundrauschen, was ihr hört,
das sind etwa 1000 Menschen, die in diesem Saal sitzen
und an vielen Tischen an bunten, blinkenden LED-Installationen
vor ihren Laptops sitzen und jeder an unterschiedlichen Grammiersprachen,
unterschiedliche Regierungssysteme hacken.
Nein, hier wird doch nichts Illegales gemacht.
Übrigens, jetzt siehst du gerade über den Raum und wolltest dich selber vorstellen.
Richtig, wir stellen es erstmal als Person vor.
Und dann können wir erzählen.
Für die Hallo-Swift-Hörer.
Liebe Hallo-Swift-Hörer.
Das, genau, wir beide sind heute zu Gast bei Hallo-Swift und Hallo-Swift ist heute zu Gast bei Akronomisierbar.
Ich bin Hendrik von Akronomisierbar und neben mir sitzt der Kilian von Akronomisierbar.
Genau, und wir sind heute, wie du schon sagst,
wer ist jetzt der Primär-Podcast?
Wir sind beide Primär-Podcasts, kein Master-Slave-Verhältnis hier.
Ja, das ist alles gleichberechtigt.
Joint-Venture.
Joint-Venture machen wir.
Genau, ich bin der Kilian.
Ich war schon mal bei euch zu Gast in einer Folge.
Und jetzt hier wieder.
Genau, und wir haben noch weitere Teilnehmer.
Du warst ja auch für unseren letzten Podcast
durchaus in der Diskussion als Gast,
aber wir wollten dich in voller Frische hier.
Das war schon mal zuerst bei Hallo Swift, oder?
Ja.
Für uns ist das auch eine Premiere, dass wir so als Person direkt nebeneinander aufnehmen.
Das stimmt.
Teilweise zumindest.
Also ihr macht das immer online und unterhaltet euch.
Jeder sitzt vor seinem Laptop mit seinem professionellen Mikrofon und ihr sprecht da rein.
Und wir treffen uns meistens irgendwie im ASCII oder bei mir zu Hause und legen unser Telefon in die Mitte.
Wir sind geografisch und viel verteilter.
Also ich bin ja in Dresden, Vincent in Berlin.
Wir stellen uns das mal weiter vor.
Genau, ich bin Vincent von Hallo Swift und bin aus Berlin.
und vor
dreiviertel Jahren ungefähr
Heidershift beigetreten oder zugestoßen
quasi, um eine Aufgabe zu zählen.
Ja,
auch ein langer,
also ein relativ langer
Hörer jetzt von Akonomi
war.
Kam leider noch nicht zum Hören
der letzten Ausgabe. Das wird dann jetzt
wahrscheinlich meine
Beschäftigung für die Rückfahrt sein.
gegenseitige Bauchpinselei hier. Schrecklich.
Und sag mal jetzt im Ernst. Hallo Swift.
Redet ihr die ganze Zeit nur über Swift?
Ja.
Nein, wir streiten auch viel.
Nein, es geht nicht primär um Swift. Es geht
eher allgemein um Apple-Themen.
Aber wir wollten heute eigentlich nur über Swift reden.
Ach so, klar. Oder bin ich schlecht vorbereitet?
Ich komme aber die Runde noch
kurz zu Ende. Bist du fertig? Okay, also ich bin
Ben von Hallo Swift. Hallo Akronomisierbar.
Also Hallo Akronomisierbar
Hörer und Hallo Akronomisierbar.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Ich glaube, unsere Zuhörer überschneiden sich stark genug, dass ich mich nicht weiter vorstellen muss.
Das sind alles Leute, die mir persönlich von dem Podcast erzählt haben, die ihn seitdem abonnieren.
Okay, ja, dann, ich würde vielleicht weiter mal mit dem kurzen Disclaimer.
Wir sind, wie gesagt, auf dem Chaos Communication Kongress. Es geht heute nicht um Swift.
Ich glaube, für euch ist das nicht so das Problem, weil ihr sehr breite Thema Auswahl habt.
Ja, falls euch das jetzt nicht interessieren sollte, dann...
Für die Hallo Swift-Hörer, wir sind dafür bekannt, nie vom Thema abzuweichen.
Wir reden immer nur über ein Topic, was wir uns zum Anfang hin festlegen und machen genau das.
Wenn wir es mal schaffen, uns auf ein Thema festzulegen.
Was wir jedes Mal schaffen.
Und auch ganz kurze Folgen, also länger als fünf Minuten geht das.
Nee, nee, ist ganz, ganz kurz.
Nee, wie du schon sagst, wir sind auf dem Kongress.
Coole Location.
Auf jeden Fall.
Und wie Hendrik auch schon gesagt hat, wir sitzen hier bei den Assemblies.
Aber vielleicht sollten wir erst mal kurz erklären, was das ist.
Was ist denn der Kongress?
Was ist der Kongress?
Oh, jetzt hört er aber weit aus.
Wir haben ja ein begrenztes Zeitreparator.
Wir dürfen hier, glaube ich, nur noch so eine dreiviertel Stunde
höchstens sitzen, dann kommen hier die nächsten Podcaster.
Und wir sitzen nämlich hier im Hintergrund,
und das finde ich eigentlich gerade ganz aufregend, also du, Ben,
hast ja den Rücken in den Saal rein, aber ich schaue hier
gerade, äh, sehen
Nikolaus Wöhl und gerade war da
ein Tilo Jung und
ein Tim Fittler läuft hier rum
und andere Leute, die man vielleicht
nur von der Stimme her kennt und deren Gesichter ich jetzt gar nicht
erkenne, aber das ist hier so die Ecke, wo die ganzen
Podcaster rumhören. Das ist ein ganz, ganz
starker Personenkult hier, also.
Ja, das ist eigentlich fast,
Das Faszinierende am Chaos Communication Kongress und am Club ist, dass eigentlich schon einige von den Leuten,
die man hier so mit einer Pommes-Schlange stehen sieht oder irgendwie die mit einem zusammen in die Talks reingehen,
dass das eigentlich schon seit Jahren quasi prominent ist, obwohl sie es nicht sein wollen und sollen,
aber ein Frank Krieger oder eine Constanze Kurz oder ein Linus Neumann hat man schon zigmal irgendwie im Fernsehen gesehen
oder in Radiointerviews, weil die Experten sind, die zu den ganzen wichtigen Themen immer angesprochen sind.
und hier steht man halt so mal eben irgendwo da
und da steht jemand neben einem, den man kennt.
Oder man hat diesen Hendrik, diesen Winzer
oder diesen Ben schon so oft im Podcast-Player gehört.
Wie kann man die endlich mal über den Weg laufen?
Das ist super cool.
Ja, oder so Leute wie Tim Pridloff.
Die Stimme habe ich jetzt schon 100.000 Stunden lang am Stück gehört,
aber eigentlich ist es ja ein komplett fremder.
Das ist schon ein erstaunliches Rezept.
Das stimmt.
Du bist ja jetzt zum ersten Mal hier.
Vielleicht, um ganz, ganz kurz in ein, zwei Sätzen zu sagen, was denn so der Kongress ist.
Wie würdest du denn jetzt als ein Kongress-Neuling den Kongress charakterisieren?
Oder wie würdest du ihn beschreiben an jemand, der ihn ebenfalls nicht kannte?
Also hier vorne steht ein Schild, was das meine Sachen super beschreibt.
Da steht drauf, endlich mal normale Leute hier.
Und das ist wirklich so, also aus meiner Perspektive zumindest.
Ich würde mich selber als Nerd bezeichnen, aber ich, keine Ahnung,
Ich bin jetzt nicht so super crazy, verrückt.
Aber hier sind ja die ganzen Verrückten.
Und da fühlt man sich aber einfach super zu Hause.
Also ich zumindest.
Und deswegen dieses endlich mal normale Leute ist wirklich ernst gemeint.
Ich fühle mich ja wirklich wie zu Hause.
Obwohl ich zum ersten Mal hier bin.
Zum ersten Mal in Leipzig hier im Messezentrum.
Und zum ersten Mal auf dem Kongress.
Aber ich fühle mich richtig wohl.
Und hier sind 15.000 aktuell.
Hier sind 15.000 Leute.
16.000 sogar.
15.000 wurde mir aus.
Schöne Runde.
Wahnsinnig viel auf jeden Fall.
Und das wird ja scheinbar auch immer größer.
Wie viel haben das letzte Jahr? 12.000?
Offiziell 12, ja.
Iloffiziell wohl noch ein bisschen mehr.
Also der Kongress ist in den letzten Jahren enorm gewachsen.
Mein erster Kongress war der 28C3.
Bist du alt?
Opa erzählt vom Krieg.
Naja, so lange ist es auch noch nicht hier.
Und das war noch der letzte in Berlin.
Das waren 4000 Leute und das war zum Bersten voll.
Und danach sind sie nach Hamburg gezogen.
Dann waren es 6, dann waren es ein Jahr drauf 8,
dann waren es 10 und dann 12.000 Leute.
Und dann sind sie aus Hamburg wieder weggetrunken.
Also dieses stetige Wachstum ist erstaunlich.
Das ist ja auch ein großer Unterschied jetzt. In den vorangegangenen Ausgaben war das ja jeweils im Kongresszentrum. Wir sitzen zwar jetzt auch gerade im Kongresszentrum von der Messe Leipzig, allerdings ist das lediglich so ein Miniteil von der eigentlichen ganzen Fläche.
Da sind ja noch drei riesengroße Messerhallen dabei und noch eine riesengroße Glasralle in der Mitte.
Glaswurst.
Ja genau, mit so einem halber Glastube quasi mit riesengroßen Laserschauen und allem Kram. Alles bunt. Das wäre so eine zweite Beschreibung, alles bunt.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Das wirkt aber auch nur im Dunklen, muss man dazu sagen.
Also jetzt gerade die Lesershow.
Ich finde jetzt auch so von den Teilnehmern,
die Diversität, ja.
Das ist eine extrem inklusive Community.
Das finde ich eigentlich so schön, dass
das so gewachsen ist, weil es extrem viele
mehr Leute aufnimmt, als nur die, die man
so weitgehend als Hacker bezeichnen würde.
Es sind extrem viele Künstler da, es sind auch extrem viele
Leute, die nicht sehr technisch sind da.
Dafür, dass fast alle schwarz tragen,
ist es trotzdem extrem gut.
Ich finde, das Miteinander,
das ist hier wirklich wahnsinnig.
Das habe ich so noch nie erlebt, weder in so einer großen Menschenansammlung,
auch noch in kleineren.
Zum Beispiel gestern standen wir in einer riesengroßen Schlange,
weil wir in den Saal wollten für den Talk.
Und da kamen Leute an und haben gefragt,
ja, wo kann ich mich denn hier anstellen?
Ja, dort hinten irgendwo so 10 Kilometer gefühlt,
wenn die nach hinten gehen.
Ja, würde ich dir aber nicht mehr empfehlen,
du kommst wahrscheinlich nicht mehr rein.
Was man normalerweise kennt, so, ach, verdammt,
jetzt komme ich hier nicht mehr rein, sowas Blödes.
Nein, die Leute lachen, okay, danke schön und gehen weiter.
Dieses Miteinander ist unglaublich.
Das ist wirklich einmalig.
Es gibt ja diese klassische Story vom Chaos Camp, wo jemand sein Laptop unbeaufsichtig hat stehen lassen
und anstelle, dass das Ding irgendwie weg war oder sonst was, kam er halt wieder und steckt ein Stromkabel dran, damit er nicht ausgeht.
Das ist halt die Art von Leuten, die man hier um sich hat.
Hat jemand den Dürcher mit nichts gesperrt?
Also hier ist aber auch der einzige Ort, wo ich meinen Laptop rumliegen lassen würde.
Also natürlich mit Passwort und Kram und mit Fingerabdrucks gerne ausgeschaltet und so ein Kram.
Aber ansonsten würde ich meinen Laptop keine 10 Sekunden Unbauaufsicht irgendwo liegen lassen, wenn da Menschen sind.
Und wo liegt dein Laptop jetzt gerade?
Den habe ich nicht dabei.
Der erste Eindruck, den ich eigentlich hatte,
bevor ich das erste Mal bei einem Kongress war,
ist, naja, ich nehme am besten
einen extra Laptop mit, nicht irgendeinen,
wo ich mein privates Zeugs drauf habe,
sondern ich nehme mir irgendwie ein frisches System mit
und ich nehme am besten die ganze Zeit für alles
ein VPN und dann habe ich
am ersten Jahr habe ich mich echt für alles, was ich gemacht habe,
durch ein VPN getunnelt
und habe mir gedacht, es sind bestimmt Leute,
die mich angreifen werden oder sowas.
aber vielleicht sind es ja Leute da.
Es gibt sicherlich Leute, die das Know-how haben,
aber niemand, der das gegen die Teilnehmer...
Also man sieht selten irgendwas,
dass irgendwas passiert gegenüber anderen Teilnehmern,
die irgendwie ausgenutzt werden.
Also passiert einfach quasi gar nicht.
Das ist jetzt die Stelle, wo die Leute uns Kommentare schreiben.
Gut, dass wir keine Kommentare haben.
Sowieso ist ja eine der besonderen Sachen am Kongress,
dass einfach alles von freiwillig und organisiert ist.
Das finde ich zum Beispiel extrem attraktiv am Kongress.
Es gibt keine Werbung.
Niemand will dir irgendwas verkaufen.
Und alles wird von Freibling organisiert.
Wenn du zum Kongress reinkommst und dann dein Bändchen hochzeigst,
dann die Personen, die quasi da in Security-Schicht schieben,
sind Teilnehmer, die eine Karte gekauft haben und dann sagen,
hey, ich stehe jetzt trotzdem zwei Stunden hier und würde mich nicht vom Pack kontrollieren,
die Besucher.
Das ist Vertrauen.
Das ist auch Wahnsinn.
Wir sind ja 15.000 Leute.
Trotzdem kannst du hier reinträgen, was du möchtest.
Keine Rucksäcke werden kontrolliert, du musst nicht durch irgendwelche
Sicherheitsschranken oder so.
Die dürften knapp 60.000 Glasflaschen.
Ja, richtig, Glasflaschen ist auch so ein Ding.
Hast du normalerweise bei großen Verständnungen nicht.
Ja, eigentlich ist es so ein bisschen wie ein Festival.
Und wir verkaufen uns die Glasflaschen selber.
Die Leute, die Glasflaschen, also vor der Theke und hinter der Theke
sind beides Teilnehmer.
Aber trotzdem ist es,
dann würdest du ja sagen, komm,
willst du mir nicht eine Marte-Flasche
zugeben?
Marte-Glasflaschen natürlich.
Auch die Art und Weise, wie das organisiert wird,
über dieses Engelsystem.
Also Engel sind quasi alle, die sich irgendwie engagieren wollten, auf irgendeinem Level helfen wollen und irgendwas tun, egal was.
Und da kann man sich halt anmelden, nee, ich bin nicht übrigens quasi in Anführungsstrichen nur Teilnehmer, sondern ich will auch engeln.
Das ist schön, dass Verb mitnutzen das Ganze.
Und da kann man eben hier rumengeln wie sonst was und seine Zeit im Höhle verbringen noch.
Nee, man kann nicht rumengeln wie sonst was.
Letztes Jahr war das obere Limit der Engel erreicht.
Da haben sich mehr Leute freiwillig gemeldet, um zu helfen, als tatsächlich angenommen werden konnte.
Ich habe ja nicht geschaut, aber ich meine, dieses Jahr sind auch über 3000 Engel.
Also es waren 2400 schon am Tag 0 irgendwo mal drin, mal geschaut gehabt, aber es müssten noch gut Spass dazugekommen sein.
Das war beeindruckend. Das sind alles freiwillige Helfer, die irgendwas übernehmen.
Tag 0 ist auch noch so ein Funfact. Also der offizielle Beginn war der 26. und das ist Tag 1.
Und ich war zum Beispiel Tag 0 da, weil ich hier mein Assembly aufgesinnt, zumindest mal markieren wollte.
Und es gibt aber eigentlich Leute, die bereits vor den Weihnachtsfeiertagen hier waren
und mit Schweißeskraft diese ganzen Installationen aufgebaut haben.
Also wenn man hier in den großen Hallen rumgeht,
das ist wirklich eine ganze Menge körperlicher Arbeit in die Installation dieser einzelnen Ständige-Furse.
Und das waren alles Freiwillige.
Ich bin auch bisher immer zu Tag 0 gekommen und Tag N plus 1 gegangen,
wo du noch ein bisschen beim Aufbauen helfen kannst.
Zwar jetzt nicht groß mit der Orga dabei und konkrete Projekte,
einfach halt dann im Heaven rumsitzen und
bereitstehen, wenn jemand,
wenn ein Erzengel, so heißen ja dann die
jeweiligen Organisatoren im Heaven,
wenn die sagen, hier, wir brauchen nochmal gerade
vier Leute, die bitte mal gerade einen Gewiss
schleppen oder so. Und dann
am quasi Tag nach dem Kongress
dann halt jegliche
Farbfolien von
den Lichtern wieder reißen,
weil das ist auch eine der charakteristischen
Sachen, es gibt hier eigentlich
so gut wie keine weißen Rampen
mehr. Die sind alle farblich über
überklebt und dementsprechend
trägt das unter anderem dazu bei, warum hier alles so bunt ist.
Und das macht einfach unglaublich
Stimmung. Das war so meine große
Furcht, als es jetzt von einem
relativ kleinen Hamburg-Kongresszentrum
zu dem einfach gigantisch großen
für Kongressverhältnisse
zu dem gigantisch großen
Leipzig-
Kongresszentrum hier, wo ich einfach sagen würde,
das ist mindestens dreimal so groß.
Das ist kein Kongresszentrum,
das ist ein Messezentrum.
Kongresszentrum ist ein Teil davon zumindest.
Ich würde behaupten, du könntest den Kongress auch einfach in der mittleren Glashalle veranstalten.
Das würde vollkommen reichen.
Das ist bereits größer als das BCC, wo wir noch vor ein paar Jahren waren.
Genau, und darum herum sind jetzt noch vier gigantische Messehallen,
wo dann teilweise die eigentlichen Säle reingebaut sind mit Tribünen,
die zum Teil dann irgendwie so ein Viertel des Saales nutzen.
Also da ist noch Raum zur Erweiterung auf jeden Fall da.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass man mehrere Vortragssäle in einer dieser Hallen tun würde.
Nö, aber du kannst noch ein paar Reihen rechts und links dazustellen, wenn es dir jetzt nicht reicht.
Und eine weitere Sache, in den letzten Jahren war es oftmals wirklich, wirklich schwierig, in den Talks noch reinzukommen.
Also speziell der kleinste Saal, der Saal G, den habe ich mir in den letzten beiden Jahren eigentlich schon fast immer ganz zu lassen.
Das war schwierig, auf jeden Fall.
Ich war gerade beim CCC-Jahresrückblick und da war, du hast ja immer so Zeremonienmeister,
Glemonienmeister, die am Anfang
und am Ende eines Talks dann nochmal so ein bisschen
Meta-Zeugs erzählen.
Wir haben gute Neuigkeiten, der Talk war gerade
super, wir haben aber auch schlechte Neuigkeiten,
die Ansage.
Falls ihr jetzt in Saal B gehen wollt,
der ist bereits voll.
Das war vor der Pause, das heißt,
da ist eigentlich anderthalb Stunden lang nichts drin gewesen.
Die Schlange war immens draußen.
Das ist hier ein bisschen schwierig. Man hat diese kleinen, schmalen
Glasdurchgänge zu den einzelnen
Randhallen mit, die großen.
Das haben wir eigentlich noch gar nicht erwähnt. Also hier werden
gehalten. Was macht man eigentlich auf dem Kongress?
147 war mein letzter Tag.
147 Talks, die gehalten werden.
Beeindruckend. Zu den verschiedensten
Themen. Also man hat immer grob ein Motto. Dieses Jahr ist
das 2Watt angelehnt an ein
also ich meine, das kommt als
Titel von dem Text, der damals zum
Aufruf den CTC zu gründen, beziehungsweise das ist das, was
da auch passiert wurde. War der Titel
2Watt.txt. Haben wir glaube ich in unserer letzten
Folge auch mal kurz angesprochen.
Und das hat man
grob als Motto, woran man das orientieren kann, aber das ist natürlich sehr
sehr breit gefächert und es gibt verschiedene Tracks,
in denen die Talks auch mit organisiert werden.
Da hat Vincent mir gerade eine Liste mitgelegt.
Es gibt Art and Culture, es gibt direkt
zum CCC, es gibt Entertainment, Ethics,
Society and Politics, Thema Freifunk,
Hardware and Making, Resilience,
Science, Security und dann noch komplett
selbstorganisierte Sessions. Also da gibt es eine
volle Bandbreite, wo man quasi alles irgendwo unterbringen
kann. Sehr, sehr viele Möglichkeiten
und es gibt auch echt viele sehr, sehr tolle Talks,
die sehr zu empfehlen sind. Und das Beste,
die werden nicht nur aufgenommen, sondern auch
live gestreamt. Also man findet die Aufnahmen immer auf Media
.ccc.de und die
Streams halt live direkt dazu
mit Untertiteln live direkt
dazu oder auch halt später in den Aufnahmen.
Und Gebärdensprache. Und Gebärdensprache
teilweise auch mit in verschiedenen Sprachen.
Live-Übersetzung, wenn man vor Ort ist, kann man einfach
über das Telefon einwählen. Was übrigens auch
freiwillig machen. Das ist alles, also diese
Infrastruktur, die flasht mich einfach immer wieder.
Was hier einfach aufgezogen wird, das ist
unglaublich. Auf einem Level, das kann man
sich gar nicht vorstellen. Das würde ich auch gerade sagen.
Also diese Talks, die sind nicht nur inhaltlich richtig gut,
sondern die sind technisch sowas von on point.
Also das habe ich noch nie erlebt, dass das,
also wie gerade schon gesagt wurde,
die nehmen ja bloß ein Viertel der Halle ein
und werden dann so in die Mitte so schräg reingemacht.
Und da drin die Belichtung, die ist perfekt.
Also da steckt so viel Liebe zum Detail drin.
Die Soundqualität ist unglaublich gut,
obwohl das sich wirklich auf eine große Menge verteilt.
Das wird halt seit 30 Jahren von Hackern gemacht.
Das sind absolute Vollprofis.
Also letztes Jahr, es gibt immer,
es gibt unterschiedliche Gruppen,
die für unterschiedliche Infrastrukturbereiche hier zuständig sind.
Es gibt das VOG und das NOC zum Beispiel.
Und es gibt noch ein paar andere OCs, die mir gerade nicht einfallen.
Aber zum Beispiel das VOG hat letztes Jahr angefangen
und zum Schneiden oder zumindest für die Produktion der Videos
und einfach eine eigene Videosoftware zum Einsatz gebracht.
Das ist das Video Operation Center?
Video Operation Center, genau.
Das andere ist das Network Operation Center.
Und die haben einfach mittlerweile eine Übung
oder eine Professionalität, die erstaunlich ist.
Das ist beeindruckend.
Also schreib mal bitte deine eigene Software,
die den ganzen Scheiß meldet.
Und man merkt aber auch, dass es Hacker sind,
weil die kommen dann teilweise auch extrem witzige, kreative Lösungen zu allgemeinen Problemen.
Also irgendwann gab es mal einen Stream auf einer Bühne,
wo dann die Zeit lang das Podium gefilmt wurde und dann plötzlich kam der Speaker auf die Bühne
und die Leute im Stream meinen, der ist gar nicht auf die Bühne gekommen.
Und dann hat man live gesehen, doch, der steht da auf der Bühne und es ist den Leuten aufgefallen,
ah, der Stream war eingefroren.
Was macht man dagegen?
Man muss irgendwie messen können, ob dieses Bild eingefroren ist.
Seitdem stehen seit einigen Jahren auf den Podien diese geilen goldenen asiatischen Winkelkatzen und winken die ganze Zeit und produzieren einfach ein konstitulierlich sich bewegendes Bild, um zu sehen, ob dieses Typ noch wird.
Das ist eine derartig geile, gehackte, aber putzige Lösung, dass man das einfach bloß feiern muss.
Die Winkelkatze sind auch ein Symbol geworden mittlerweile. Auf jeden Fall.
Wo du gerade Network Operations Center sagtest, dir wird ja auch eine Infrastruktur aufgefallen, die ist unglaublich.
Also man hat drei WLANs.
Das ist das eine, also wahrscheinlich das eine, was jeder nutzt.
Das ist aber gar nicht alles.
Man hat hier auch eine komplette Telefoninfrastruktur.
Also hier gibt es Leute, die rennen mit ihrem Deck-Telefon rum.
Bis vor ein paar Jahren konntest du dir SIM-Karten abholen.
Gibt es diese auch noch?
Ich habe auch eine SIM-Karte.
Hier ist ein komplettes GSM-Netz.
Ein eigenes GSM-Netz.
Zieh das mal bitte auf.
Es ist leider sehr experimentell und funktioniert noch nicht ganz.
Wir konnten jetzt schon SMS verschicken.
Anrufen funktioniert irgendwie von GSM zu Deck.
Keine Ahnung.
Kommt wahrscheinlich noch, aber es ist ja schon mal total krass, dass es überhaupt versucht wird
und überhaupt schon so weit gekommen ist.
Wahnsinn. Richtig, richtig gut.
Because we can.
Nur deswegen.
Genau das.
Es wird ja auch sinnvoll genutzt.
Es gibt ja dann, wenn du halt ein paar tausend Nerds aufeinander hast,
dann wird natürlich eine Menge Mate getrunken und die leeren Flaschen müssen irgendwo hin.
Und dementsprechend hast du hier an jeder zweiten Ecke eine Mate-Flaschen-Sammelstellen.
Und die haben in der Regel alle eine dieser vierstelligen, also dieses interne Telefonnetz hat vierstellige Rufnummern.
Ich bitte übrigens die Leute, die uns gerade live zu hören, kriege ich jetzt Aufmerksamkeit, ja.
Ruf doch mal bitte alle die Nummer 1, 2, 3, 4 an.
Wer ist das? Wo geht das hin?
Das ist, glaube ich, Tim Pridler.
Okay, also Frey Weber ist sie nämlich nicht. Man hat nur Nummer zwischen 2100 und 8000.
Ich habe nämlich heute aus dem letzten
Lockheed-Platzpolitik erfahren, dass die
Einzernummern nur die Prominenten kriegen.
Ich wollte eigentlich auch 1337
nehmen, aber ging leider nicht.
Ich bin gestern, ich bin ja mit dem Auto
hier, weil ich glücklicherweise ursprünglich aus dieser
Gegend komme und jeden Tag mit dem Auto hier herpendeln
darf und das ist ein erstaunlich kurzer
Weg. Und ich stehe hier auf dem Parkplatz
und bin gestern mal zum Spaß rumgelaufen, weil ich habe ja
so ein, ich habe mir auch ein Vanity
Number Plate gegönnt, als ich dieses Auto angemeldet habe.
Ich habe 1337 auf dem Kennzeichen stehen,
bin mal rumgelaufen und dachte, die haben noch bestimmt
noch andere. Dann bin ich irgendwie drei Reihen gegangen.
Ich bin überhaupt nicht über alle gegangen. Ich bin echt bloß über drei
Reihen Parkplatz mal gelaufen.
Ich habe mindestens sechs Autos
gesehen, die alle 1, 3, 3, 7 haben. Andere
hatten 1, 0 Kombinationen,
also 10, 10. Dann gab es
diverse
Zweierpotenzen und dann gab es noch
ein paar Mal 23, 43.
Sehr geil.
Alles, ihr Nerds, ihr seid so toll.
Was war das gerade mit den Matekästen?
Über jedem
dieser Landestationen hängt in der Regel
Nummer, eine dieser vierstelligen Nummern, und die rufst du an und dann gibst du noch
jeweils die Identifier-Nummer für den jeweiligen Kasten an, wenn der voll ist.
Und dann kommt irgendwann, ein paar Minuten später, ein Engel vorbei und holt die leeren
Flaschen ab und stellt einen leeren Kasten wieder hin.
Und das klingt jetzt irgendwie so, als würde man da quasi seine Dienerlein haben, die dann vorbeikommen und einem irgendwie alles da herwischen.
Aber das ist eben gerade nicht so, sondern weil jeder weiß, dass jeden Müll, den man fallen lässt, dass den ein anderer Teilnehmer aufheben muss.
Oder wenn es eben nicht passiert, dass man sich selber den Kongress vollmüllt, passiert das eben nicht.
Also es wird zwar auch immer bei den Talks aufgerufen, hier nehmt bitte nicht nur eure Flaschen mit,
sondern auch die eurer Nachbarn, wenn die dann doch mal stehen gelassen wurden.
Aber insgesamt gehört hier einfach dazu, dass man anderen Leuten keine Arbeit macht, die nicht sein muss.
Und dass man ganz im Gegenteil hilfsbereit ist, wenn andere Hilfe brauchen.
Und das finde ich immer so sehr, sehr positiv und auch so mutmachend.
Weil der Kongress zeigt einfach, dass wenn wir nur wollten, dann würde man eine andere Gesellschaft hinkriegen,
wo man nicht immer nur auf eigenen Profit und auf eigener Profilierung aus ist,
jetzt wird es politisch hier.
Es ist schade, dass es nicht skaliert, aber ich finde auch irgendwie,
der Kongress bringt immer so das Beste im Menschen hervor.
Aber skaliert es denn wirklich nicht? Also ich meine, der Kongress
wird ja auch immer größer und skaliert der Schärmer mit.
Ja, wir müssen einfach irgendwann den
Kongress 365 Tage im Jahr machen
und auch der ganzen Welt gleichzeitig.
Das Chaos-Camp dann zusätzlich.
Genau, ein weiterer Aspekt,
der auch beim Kongress wichtig ist, ist ja, dass
man darf zwar Fotos machen,
aber nur, wenn alle Abgebildeten
auf dem Foto sowohl
für sich selber als auch für ihre
vermeintlich abgebildeten Bildschirme
das okay geben.
Und das hat zur Folge, dass du eigentlich
fast keine Fotos machen kannst.
Also
du bist es ja quasi alle Leute, die irgendwie
abgebildet sind. Und du machst mal ein Foto auf dem Kongress, wo nicht
irgendwie ein halbes Dutzend Personen drauf sind.
Was schon irgendwie schade ist, weil es ist ja
ein beeindruckender Anblick, wenn man hier
durch die Reihen geht. Und das machst du immer schwierig,
wenn man mit anderen Leuten was erzählt.
Ich versuche halt möglichst keine Person drauf zu haben.
Ja gut, aber dadurch bildest du halt
auf deinen Fotos einen anderen Kongress ab, als der,
wo du eigentlich bist, weil du bist ein Kongresser, wo ja keine Menschen da sind.
Die Fotos sind halt mehr künstlerisch, mit dem ganzen Licht und der Rakete zum Beispiel,
die da unten steht.
Das Problem sind häufig so Fernsehcrews reingelaufen, die dann einen kurzen Bericht über den Kongress
machen wollten und dann sind sie von bösen Nerds angesprochen worden, dass sie bitte nicht
gefilmt werden.
Die sind ja auch hier, also ZDF haben schon gesehen.
Genau, die Presse darf sich nicht über den Kongress bewegen, ohne einen Presseengel
dabei zu haben, der eben darauf aufpasst, dass die Presse nicht gesehen hat.
Der ZDF hat nämlich den gesamten Talk heute Morgen gefilmt gehabt und die sind so ein
Stück zurückgegangen, das ist ein bisschen aus der Ferne und da sind dann auch zwei
Engel mitgegangen, die dir exakt aufgepasst haben, dass niemand vom Publikum
mit drauf war.
Die Presse ist irgendwie hier im Zentrum, ist die irgendwie
in der Wickelecke oder sowas untergebracht.
Das ist richtig.
Ja, das haben wir dabei.
Es gibt auch einen Pressesprecher vom Club, der direkt am Eingang steht.
Es gibt eigentlich
immer so einen delizierten Presseraum, wo auch
Podiumsdiskussionen dann
teilweise vom Radio organisiert werden.
Ja genau, aber dieser delizierte Presseraum ist halt
der
Kinderbetreuungsraum der
so ein paar Tweets, die das in der Foto hat.
Das klingt jetzt so, als wäre ja, das würde ja total
für illegales Zeug abgehen oder so. Im Endeffekt geht es ja
aber eher um Privatsphäre und ich glaube, es wird auch prinzipiell
auch ein bisschen auf die Spitze getrieben einfach.
Naja, einfach nur, weil wir uns mal eben zeigen wollen,
dass es mal weiter treiben muss.
Bitte macht keinen Scheiß und achtet mal drauf.
Hier, wenn nicht, oder sonst wo.
Es gibt auch in der Messe ganz viele Überwachungskameras
natürlich, die alle ausgeschaltet sind für den Konkurs.
Fand ich auch sehr interessant.
Sowieso lässt sich ja der CCC quasi
Wochen vorher die Schlüssel geben
und gibt sie dann ein paar Tage später wieder zurück.
und übernimmt aber dazwischen komplett den Laden.
Das ist mehr oder weniger auch so eine Bedingung dafür,
quasi in der Auswahl der Venue oder dieser Kongress-Stadt-Welle.
Das ist auch nochmal ein starkes Vertrauen in die Besucher.
Also ein riesig großes sogar.
Das war zum Beispiel, wenn ich mich nicht erinnere,
war das ein großes Problem mit Frankfurt.
Also die Messe Frankfurt mehr oder weniger ist ausgeschieden,
weil die einfach gedacht haben, nee, Schlüssel geben wir euch nicht.
Was, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, absurd ist,
weil unglaublich viele, die bei der Messe Frankfurt die IT machen,
sind halt hier diejenigen, die auch beim Kongress
wesentlich mit...
Ja, aber das sind ja nicht die, die entscheiden.
Nee, aber weißt du, die eigentlichen Mitarbeiter,
die sonst während dem Jahr
für sie arbeiten und genau den Laden
eben schmeißen,
denen traut man nicht zu, dass sie
da irgendwie anständig
den Kongress schmeißen,
was sie seit 34 Jahren machen und beweisen,
dass es einfach geht.
Wo Schlüssel geben habt ihr eigentlich...
Also man hat es in Hamburg immer die letzten Jahre gesehen,
Das ist ja das CCH, das Congress Center Hamburg wahrscheinlich.
Da wurde ja das, draußen steht auch groß ein CCH dran.
Da wurde das H immer schön überklebt mit einem riesigen leuchtenden C.
Wird davor gehangen, dann hing halt groß draußen ein CCC dran.
Hier hat sich gestern, habe ich komisch gefunden, dass draußen noch ein CCL groß dran klebt.
Aber heute früh, als ich gekommen bin, war das L auch schon ungemodelt zu einem weiteren C.
Also es hat sich lange auf sich warten lassen.
Das ist typografisch nicht ganz einheitlich.
Das sieht doch etwas broken aus, aber es stimmt auf jeden Fall.
Das machen wir mal als Chapter-Marktbild mit Renn.
Genau
Wir haben es wirklich
Achso, dann lasse ich nicht die Edit machen
Ich glaube wir haben es auch schon einmal gemacht
Aber eigentlich ist es bei uns so ein bisschen ein Mähmend
Das wir bereits in der letzten Folge schon wieder gesagt haben
An dieser Stelle nehmen wir das als Bild mit rein
Ich habe sie in die Show Notes gemacht
Nee, das ist bei uns ein bisschen Running Jack
Ich darf jetzt nicht mehr in die Chapter Marks packen, sonst wäre es ja korrekt
Ja, ist auch super aufwendig
Die ganzen Chapter Marks machen wir in den Bildern und alles
Zu den Talks nochmal
Die laufen ja etliche coole Sachen
Das haben wir schon ein paar Mal gesagt gehabt
Was für coole Sachen liefen da denn beispielsweise?
Was habt ihr so angeschaut?
Also, ich war ganz am Anfang in der Eröffnung von Tim Pridloff.
Die war relativ kurz, aber ganz schön.
Hat das auch nochmal so ein bisschen auf den Punkt gebracht.
War für mich halt ziemlich cool, weil ich halt das erste Mal hier bin.
Und da so eine Einführung ist schon ganz cool gewesen.
Er hat auf jeden Fall auch schön auf die Geschichte des Klubs nochmal eingegangen
und ist auf dieses Motto, was wir dieses Jahr tragen, Tuwad eingegangen, wo es herkommt.
Achso, gut.
Wenn ich angeschaut, die Eröffnung vielleicht wäre es.
Das war cool.
ein Video von
Wow Holland, der war einer der Gründer,
gezeigt. Und der hatte das
Video, was sie gezeigt haben, ist von 1999 gewesen.
Und er hat damals, wie gesagt, der Club ist jetzt erwachsen
geworden, weil er da irgendwie 18 Jahre alt geworden
war. Und das Video ist ja schon wieder 18
Jahre her. Also der ist jetzt quasi nochmal erwachsen geworden.
Das fand ich ganz schön. Das ist halt schon Wahnsinn.
Wisst ihr eigentlich, warum, wenn der
Club jetzt quasi 36 ist, warum der Kongress nur
34 ist? Fing das später an oder gab es da mal eine Pause?
Die haben sich sofort mit einem Kongress angefangen
zu organisieren. Das ging ein paar
Jahre vor sich hin und dann haben die auch mal gedacht,
so, jetzt lass uns mal ein Treffen machen.
Das war ursprünglicherweise, der allererste
Kongress war in Hamburg und ist dann
nach Berlin gezogen. Aber nicht im Kongresszentrum.
Das wäre nie was.
In irgendeinem Brauhaus.
Irgendeinem Keller.
In der Besenkammer des Kongresszentrums.
Ja, ich würde mal sagen,
was ich so für ein Talk cool fand.
Wir können ja mal über die Runde rumgehen.
Soll ich überhaupt anfangen?
Beide Podcasts grob so ein Konzept von Picks
oder Stars oder Beliebungen.
Das habe ich doch angesprochen.
Okay, dann pickt jetzt jeder ein oder mehrere Talks.
Ich fange mal an mit.
Heute früh, also heute ist übrigens der zweite Tag,
da war ein Talk Social Bots, Fake News und Filterblasen.
Der war ziemlich cool.
Da hat Michael Kreil, der hat so ein Projekt gestartet gehabt,
wo er Twitter-Daten sammeln wollte und hat dafür so einen kleinen Web-Service gestartet,
wo man eben mithelfen konnte, indem man seine Authentication-Daten irgendwie mit angibt,
sodass er dann über diese Authentication-Daten,
von den jeweiligen Twitter-Nutzer parallel Daten von der Twitter-API scoren konnte.
Das ist ziemlich cool.
Jeder Twitter-Benutzer kann nur einen API-Key generieren.
Allerdings kannst du mit einem API-Key nur eine bestimmte Anzahl Anfragen machen.
Deswegen hat er dazu aufgerufen, dass du deinen API-Key spendest,
damit er mehr Anfragen machen kann, indem er einfach viele API-Keys vorhanden kann.
Genau, da haben knapp 700 Leute sich mit angemeldet gehabt,
sodass er dann ungefähr 10 Requests die Sekunde machen konnte.
Was wohl bedeutet, er hat gemeint, er könnte in vier Tagen
halt mal so alle Tweets scannen in einem bestimmten
Zeitraum. Ich weiß gerade nicht mehr, was für ein Zeitraum.
Genau, der hat ja ziemlich coole Auswertungen gemacht.
Ich würde da jetzt gar nicht so tief drauf eingehen, aber das lohnt sich
auch schon, finde ich. Also es ging
ja zum größten auch um Social Bots,
wie es mit drin steht.
Das Böse, Neue, was jetzt uns alle beeinflusst
und Wahlen beeinflusst und sowas. Und hat auch ein bisschen
gezeigt, dass das eben nicht der Fall ist und warum.
Und ja, lohnt sich auf jeden Fall.
Passenderweise, bloß als kleine
Zwischenbemerkung heute früh, kamen wir in den Nachrichten, dass die
Library of Congress
in den USA, ist das
die erste Library of Parliament?
Library of Congress gibt es auf jeden Fall.
Die sich eigentlich vorgenommen hatten, alle Twitter-Tweets
zu archivieren,
weil das ja Zeitgeschehen
abbildet.
Die haben sich erst
rückwirkend auf Datenbanken von Twitter
geben lassen und haben es dann jahrelang aufgezeichnet.
Die haben heute bekannt gegeben, dass sie dann aufhören.
Weil sie es einfach nicht mehr
gebacken kriegen, weil es nicht mehr skaliert.
Ja, weil auch ganz viel gelöscht wird.
Also der hat ja auch so ein paar Dinge gezeigt,
die einfach schon gelöscht waren, die dann gar nicht mehr auswertbar waren.
Vor allem auch Twitter-Accounts.
Er hat ja eben Social Bots, das heißt also Bot-Nutzer,
die ja auch jetzt gar nicht so legal auf der Plattform sind.
Und die werden natürlich relativ schnell weggelöscht.
Deswegen, das ist natürlich auch für ihn schwierig.
Da caches das halt alles zwischen und dann geht das wieder.
Aber muss man auch oft anfragen.
Ich habe meinen ersten Talk, den ich jetzt nach der Keynote besucht habe,
war Forensic Architecture.
Das ist eine Organisation, die ich schon vorher kannte.
Das ist ein aus Israel kommender Architekt, der in London ein Labor hat,
die ihr Architekturwissen nutzen, um im Endeffekt Morde aufzuklären.
Aus richtiger Gebäudearchitektur.
Genau, richtige Gebäudearchitekten.
Und die haben zum Beispiel unter anderem, es gab einen dieser NSU-Morde,
wo ein Verfassungsschutzmitarbeiter mit in dem Internetcafé war,
wo der Besitzer des Cafés erschossen wurde.
Und der Verfassungsschutzmitarbeiter saß im Nebenzimmer,
schon mal ein schöner Zufall,
und hat von sich selber behauptet, er hätte weder was gehört,
noch was gesehen, noch was gerochen.
Auch als er dann mehr oder weniger zum gleichen Zeitpunkt das Café verlassen hat,
hat er die Leiche nicht gesehen.
Und die haben ein real großes Modell nachgebaut, alles nachgespielt,
haben Computersimulationen gemacht und geschaut,
wie mit exakt der gleichen Pistole sich das Schwarzpulver im Raum verteilt
und haben damit ganz, ganz offensichtlich beweisen können,
dass es unmöglich ist, dass er nichts gehört hat, nichts gerochen hat
und vor allem auch die Leiche nicht gesehen hat.
Und es riecht alles danach, dass er wahrscheinlich sogar wirklich
im Zweifelsfall daneben stand,
als es passiert ist.
Aber nicht selber abgedrückt hat.
Kann man das auch noch ausgießen?
Das ist so eine Sache und dann
machen die halt unglaublich viel, haben unglaublich viele
so Research-Sachen gemacht
bezüglich einem Fall, wo
politisch
Aktive in Mexiko
von der Polizei und den Narcos
irgendwie verschleppt und
im Endeffekt umgebracht wurden.
Solche Aktionen extrem gut.
Das einzig Schade an dem
und so schade war es dann doch wieder nicht im Endeffekt,
aber zu dem Moment schade an dem Vortrag war,
dass die Technik einfach nicht funktioniert hat.
Das war erstmal
ganz lustig, weil du hast dann so
fünf, sechs Nerds da vorne rumstehen vom CDC,
die es alle nicht gebacken kriegen,
den Projektor anzuwerfen,
beziehungsweise das Bild auf den Projektor zu kriegen,
sodass er dann
einen zweiten Computer nehmen musste, auf dem er dann
einfach die Website aufgerufen hat und die Filmchen dort
abgespielt hat und musste ein bisschen improvisieren.
Niemals sind halt auch nur Drucker auf einem anderen
Ja, genau.
Und der Talk war trotzdem extrem gut.
Es bildete sich nach dem Talk dann doch eine große Traube um ihn.
Und mehrere Leute haben ihn gefragt, hey, sag mal, geiler Talk, trotz allem, wo kriegen wir deine Folien, die du eigentlich zeigen wolltest?
Woraufhin er dann sagte, ja, also wenn es nach mir geht, suchen wir uns einen Raum, suchen wir uns einen Zeitpunkt.
Und dann zeige ich euch, mache ich euch den Vortrag nochmal richtig.
und dann wurde relativ schnell klar,
okay, also das mit dem Raum finden kriegen wir hin,
das mit dem Zeitpunkt
und dann wieder alle zusammenfinden wird ein bisschen schwierig,
weil
es gibt hier
keinen
Ausrufer,
der sagt, so, bitte
alle so und so auf Level 5
oder so kommen.
Aber eine App, also man könnte ja
über die App mit Possibly... Ja, da könnte man mal was machen.
Das ist ja auch nicht jede.
So, das ist dann relativ schnell dazu gekommen, dass wir gesagt haben,
okay, also komm, wir stehen jetzt schon alle um dich herum,
wir suchen jetzt einen Raum und dann schauen wir.
Du kannst alle Telefone anrufen.
Man kann ja eigentlich hier noch Assemblies anmelden oder Workshops anmelden,
die dann kommuniziert werden.
Also theoretisch, wenn er gesagt hätte,
mach mal übermorgen nochmal eine Session oder sowas.
Aber es war halt ganz praktisch, weil wir in dem Moment hatten alle irgendwie das Gefühl,
hey, wir haben sowieso Zeit, uns interessiert uns gerade jetzt.
Dann haben wir uns einen Raum gesucht, so ein typischer Seminarraum,
wo so knapp 30 Leute dann auch gefolgt sind, 20, 30 Leute.
Und dann haben wir, ich habe nicht auf die Zeit geachtet,
aber es dürften locker mindestens eine Stunde bis anderthalb Stunden.
Einfach extrem interessant, Frage, Antwort.
Weil auch dort der Bühne nicht funktioniert.
Wahrscheinlich lag es an seinem Computer.
Ein neues MacBook Pro mit den USB-C Anschlüssen.
Ja, dann liegt es da.
Die haben ja schon letztes Jahr in vielen Tops nicht funktioniert.
Und das war im Endeffekt einen geileren Vortrag,
hätte er gar nicht halten können,
als das, was er da jetzt noch in dem kleinen Seminarraum
für anderthalb Stunden einfach die extrem spezifische
und interessante Fragen beantwortet hat.
Das war super.
Das war so mein Einstieg, wo ich dachte, ja geil.
Es war voll die Hose gerade technisch,
aber besser hätte es gar nicht kommen können.
Das klingt auf jeden Fall mal anschauen.
Das klingt fantastisch.
Ein cooler Talk, den ich mir mal rausgesucht habe,
um ihn zu highlighten, an dem wir gestern geschaut haben,
war der Talk mit dem Titel
der PC-Wahl-Hack. Es geht um das, was sich
vermuten lässt, um den Hack
der PC-Wahl-10-Software,
der ja auch gut durch die Medien mitgegangen ist,
kurz vor der Bundestagswahl.
Und zwar gab es da ein paar Leute,
ein paar CTC-Mitglieder, die diese Software
auseinandergenommen, beziehungsweise an verschiedenen Stellen angegriffen
haben, Angriff ist vielleicht
das falsche Begriff an der Stelle, aber ein bisschen
dran rumgedoktert haben und mal geschaut haben, was sie da
aushebeln können,
was von den Daten ist eigentlich ungewollt
doch offen verfügbar und wo kann man da ein bisschen
rumeditieren und sind zu einem sehr erschreckenden
Ergebnis gekommen. Vieles davon hat man
ja in den Pressemitteilungen kurz vor
und vor allem nach der Bundestagswahl ja mitgekriegt.
Aber der Talk hat das alles nochmal
wunderschön auf den Punkt gebracht und auch viele
Details nochmal gezeigt.
Einfach nochmal
komplett drauf eingegangen, auf wie
vielen Ebenen die das eben komplett verhauen haben.
Und dann immer und immer und immer wieder
und dann sind sie so weit gegangen
und haben quasi ein Patch
bereitgestellt. Hier, wir merken,
ihr habt Probleme damit, eure Software in den Griff
kriegen. Ihr versucht immer wieder irgendwie
hier Verschlüsselung einzulegen und doch legt ihr die unverschlüsselten
Daten ohne jegliche Form vor Signatur
doch immer wieder öffentlich ans Netz. Ihr kriegt
das einfach nicht gebacken. Schaut mal, so
könnte man es potenziell machen,
aber die sind einfach gar nicht drauf eingegangen.
Diese Firma,
das ist eine riesen Lachnummer, was
da eben passiert ist. Das ist ein so
klassischer Talk, wo man dann einfach nur noch das Gesicht
irgendwann in den Händen versenkt und aus dem Lachen nicht mehr
herauskommt. Wie hart man einfach so ein Projekt
gegen die Wand fahren kann. Das ist großartig.
Schaut euch den bitte an.
Unglaublich amüsant.
Obwohl man dazu sagen muss,
dass es ein anderer Talk,
der gestern stattgefunden hat,
war auch jemand,
der, ich habe es jetzt leider nicht gerade rausgesucht,
jemand, der sich mit Elektro-Tankstellen,
Elektro-Ladestationen für Elektroautos,
auseinandergesetzt hat
und da herrlich zerlegt hat,
was für ein schlechtes Sicherheitskonzept
diese Tankstellen haben.
Also im Endeffekt ist es so,
dass du dir,
Disclaimer,
wenn irgendjemand eine Tankkarte hat
für elektrische Ladestationen,
lass die nie unbeobachtet.
Wenn man die ohne weiteres,
sobald man sie einmal kopiert hat, was nicht schwer ist,
dann überall zum Tanken benutzen kann.
Und das landet dann alles auf eure Rechnung.
Aber wichtig ist, dass man dazu sagt,
dass die Art und Weise, wie diese Schwachstellen hier kommuniziert werden,
nicht so ist, dass es irgendwie als Lachnummer verkauft wird,
dass die Leute, die die Software geschrieben haben,
bloßgestellt werden sollen.
Also zumindest nicht dann, wenn sie sich nicht absolut unkooperativ gezeigt haben.
Sondern der erste Ansatz ist immer,
okay, wir sehen, da gibt es Probleme.
Was kann man denn dagegen machen?
Das hat ja auch Linus Neumann und die Leute, die diesen Vortrag, den du gerade beschrieben hast, gehalten haben, mehrfach gesagt.
Also der erste Schritt ist immer erstmal zu den Leuten hingehen, sagen, ihr habt da ein Problem, freundlich bleiben und denen dann Hilfe anbieten.
Auf jeden Fall.
gemacht und wenn dann natürlich
die Softwareentwickler auf der
anderen Seite
mit Stolz und
mit Hämigkeit dann
nicht darauf eingehen und wenn sie dann was
machen, dann falsch reagieren oder
überreagieren oder gar nicht
reagieren und dann zeigen, dass sie nicht
auf diese Probleme, die
beschrieben wurden, eingehen wollen, dann wird es natürlich
für die Leute, die im Publikum sitzen, dann immer etwas
unterhaltsamer, aber eigentlich geht es ja nicht darum, dass die Leute
bloßgestellt werden. Aber am Ende
saßen dann doch wirklich viele, also
uns inklusive dort mit
quasi Händen über dem Kopf, weil es geht ja schließlich
immerhin um unsere Bundestagswahl dabei.
Wie du schon meintest, der einzig sinnvolle Alternative
wäre Demokratie abschaffen und Diktatur
einführen, weil die ist zumindest, da sind die Wahlen
sicher, da weiß man, was passiert.
Also ich war auch in dem Talk,
wollte noch dazu sagen, ich hatte mir vorher den
Podcast angehört, Logbuch Netzpolitik,
die Folge 228, wo das auch schon mit alles beleuchtet
wurde. Das heißt, die Hintergründe kannte
ich alle schon, habe mich trotzdem noch ewig angestellt
und reingesetzt, hat sich trotzdem gelohnt,
einfach schon wegen der Bilder dieser Software.
weil die sieht ja auch unglaublich gut aus.
Ja, das war so meine Vermutung. Also ich glaube,
diese Software ist bereits seit
zehn Jahren mindestens nicht mehr
weiterentwickelt worden. Es hat irgendjemand
mal verkauft, die benutzen
Techniken, FTP-Server, Ungeschützte
und... Delphi war das, ne?
Es ist Pascal geschrieben, ja.
In den 80ern wurde die ursprünglich entwickelt.
Ja, aber damit haben Leute in Deutschland
vor zehn Jahren oder so auch schon noch
Desktop-Software entwickelt. Und ich möchte behaupten, die haben das vor zehn Jahren
mal verkauft und leben seitdem von den
Lizenzkosten... Verkaufst du das erst klappt vor der Bundestagswahl?
vor sechs Monaten. Achso, das wird noch nicht
seit zehn Jahren eingesetzt? Naja, doch schon, aber es wurde
verkauft von dem ursprünglichen Entwickler für einen
siebenstelligen Betrag an den Konkurrenten.
Ich meine nicht die Firma, also das kam ja noch
dazu. Also der Auftrag
für die Wahlgeber.
Die Software wurde an den Kunden bereits ausgeliefert
und glaube seit dem ersten Mal, möchte
ich überhaupt nicht großartig verändern, die Leute,
die dahinter stecken, leben halt jetzt von den
Lizenzeinnahmen und haben
auch irgendwie keinen Incentive gehabt, daran
weiterzuarbeiten. Dementsprechend haben die jetzt natürlich
Jahre später, wenn jemand
vom Kongress, jemand vom
Club ankommt und sagt, ihr habt da
fundamentale Probleme mit und ihr müsst auch
das, das, das und das nachbessern.
Und übrigens in drei Monaten ist Bundestagswahl,
fangt mal an, dann haben die natürlich auch keinen Bock. Und da kann ich mir natürlich
sehr gut vorstellen, dass da jemand, der eigentlich schon
damit abgeschlossen hat, da irgendwann nochmal was dran zu machen,
da irgendwie die Füße hochlegt und sagt,
nö, eigentlich habe ich da keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Die können das auch gar nicht. Also das hat man ja gesehen,
als sie gezeigt haben. Also wie sie versucht haben,
ich meine, der Chaos Computer Group hat ihnen halt wirklich
detailliert gezeigt, also folgendermaßen das.
Das war ein 25-seitiges Dokument, was sie ihnen da gegeben haben, wo auch extrem detailliert steht, was sie fixen müssen.
Okay, dann lass doch mal den Tim Fridloff hier einparken.
Was und wie sie es fixen müssen.
Und sie haben einfach alles, sie haben mehrere Anläufe, drei, vier verschiedene Anläufe gehabt und sie haben es jedes Mal,
also jeweils der Worst Case, wie man diesen Fix befolgen könnte, um ihn größtmöglich zu verkacken.
Ja, schaut euch einfach mal den Talk an.
Die einzelnen Sachen, die sie so als
Verbesserung Reihe nach gemacht haben, zeigen so richtig
auf, wie sie die Technologien, die sie da eingewendet haben,
überhaupt zum ersten Mal kennengelernt und ausprobiert haben.
Genau, dass sie sich verstanden haben. Also die haben ja
zum Beispiel dann mit Hashing angefangen und haben da in D5 genommen.
Naja, oder halt dann gesagt,
okay, ah, dann sichern wir die
Sachen jetzt mit Passwörtern und dann legen sie
Passwörter in Plaintext direkt daneben
auf dem gleichen Server.
Also wir sollten gleich hinter der Story.
Schaut euch diesen.
Also wir müssen hier auf jeden Fall
das Passwort direkt rein und speichern
dann sind der Textanteil daneben und legen die auch in das
Samba-Share-Wort. Wichtig ist, es war so lange unterhaltsam,
bis man drüber nachdenkt, dass es hier um unsere
Wahlen geht. Und dann war es eigentlich eher traurig.
Das war der Punkt, wo ich dann mit der
Diktatur kam. Das ist an sich nicht so mein Motto.
Achso, das ist nicht so
generell. Dann habe ich nicht eine Diktatur als
für. Was? Ich will nicht vielleicht eingeschätzt.
Okay, außer
Talks gibt es eben auch diese
Assemblies. Die sollten wir vielleicht auch mal kurz erklären.
Am besten Händträger, Kertz, weil der hat
nämlich... Ich habe ein kleines Assembly
angemeldet, genau. Und zwar ist ein Assembly
du meldest dich vorher im Kongress-Wiki.
Jetzt plägt nochmal kurz eine Triggerwarnung für Helge.
Okay, das lassen wir jetzt einfach mal als Insider so stehen.
Helge weiß Bescheid.
Hi Helge, wir müssen mal ein Bier trinken zusammen.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wer du bist.
Und zwar kann man sich,
man muss sich diesen Raum hier vorstellen,
in dem wir sitzen, das ist voller Tische
und an jedem Tisch sitzen ganz viele Nerds
und machen unterschiedliche Sachen.
Die einzelnen Tische sind reserviert,
als Assembly-Räume. Es gibt in den größeren
Sälen gibt es auch noch andere, komplexere
Installationen, wo die Leute ganze Sofas
und ganze andere komplexe Installationen
mitgebracht haben. Busse vor allem.
Ganze Busse und so weiter und so fort. Also die großen
Hackerspaces aus Deutschland haben
riesengroße Assemblies aufgebaut. Also das
von der
Seabase ist absolut gigantisch
und bombastisch. Und wenn man
allerdings noch so eine kleine Hackergruppe oder vielleicht
ein Meetup ist, kann man sich trotzdem noch so einen kleinen Tisch für ein paar Leute
mieten. Und ich habe hier ein
ich habe jetzt schon zum dritten Mal
teilgenommen, oder dieses Jahr
habe ich selber angemeldet, an dem
Rust Community Assembly,
weil ich in der Community ein bisschen organisiert bin.
Und im Endeffekt habe ich das vorher in den Wiki eingetragen,
dann habe ich, am Tag 0
war ich hier, bin ich ein bisschen rumgelaufen, wo ich dann meinen Tisch
nehmen soll, dann habe ich da
ein Poster hingelegt.
Sehr deutsch, dein Handtuch ausgebreitet.
Naja, genau, und ich dachte mir erst, ich mache da einen
Aufkleber in die Mitte auf den Tisch und
zehn Minuten später kamen Leute an, ja, wir sitzen hier nebenan
und wir haben mir ein bisschen was mitgebracht.
Es ist okay, wenn wir hier diese schönen Tischdecken hinlegen.
Plötzlich haben wir Tischdecken auf dem Tisch liegen.
Da kam noch jemand an.
Ich hatte einen kleinen Network Switch mitgebracht,
so als Lesson Learn von den letzten Jahren.
Und ich habe mir gedacht,
eigentlich die Sachen, die man mitbringen muss zum Kongress,
sind immer Stromverteiler, hatte ich.
Network Switches hatte ich auch.
Assembly reservieren.
Und man braucht LED-Scheiß auf dem Tisch.
Ich hatte keinen LED-Scheiß mit.
Da kommt natürlich jemand von nebenan
und legt uns schön bunte LED-Lichterketten auf den Tisch.
Jetzt sind wir also an Feuer ausgerüstetes Assembly
und die Leute machen einfach mit, das ist super.
Ich war einen Großteil der Zeit gar nicht da, weil ich selber in Talks war
und jedes Mal, wenn ich wiedergekommen bin,
um so nach rechts zu sehen, sitzen andere
Leute und reden über Rust und erklären sich
das gegenseitig. Dom und ich haben eine kleine
Session gemacht und heute an Tag 2
komme ich plötzlich wieder, hat jemand eine riesengroße
orangene Rust-Krabbe
aus Pappe ausgeschnitten
und einen Aufsteller mit LEDs hingestellt
und jetzt haben wir da eine wunderschöne, ich habe das mal fotografiert,
das müssen wir mal in die Shorts auszunehmen.
Ich meine, sie heißt Emily,
Emily Dunham von Mozilla.
Ah, sehr gut. Aus dem Rust Community Team.
Also man muss auch unbedingt
auf dem Kongress
den Hashtag 34C3
abonnieren.
Da laufen auch immer
ziemlich schöne Sachen. Emily wusste nämlich gar nicht,
dass... Ich meine, sie heißt Emily, aber die nennen sie jetzt einfach mal
Emily.
Sie wusste gar nicht, dass wir ein Assembly haben.
Sie ist eigentlich Mozilla-Mitarbeiterin
und Teil der Rust Community und wusste gar nicht,
dass es ein Assembly gibt. Und es gibt
einen Twitter-Account vom
Wish-Tisch.
wo man auf dem Kongress Wünsche äußern kann
und die haben dann, da muss irgendjemand hingegangen sein
und nach einem Rust Assembly gefragt haben
und die haben dann rumgetwittert und Emily hat geantwortet
ich glaube das gibt es nicht und ich habe das mitbekommen
und habe geantwortet, doch gibt es, dort und dort
und dann ist er offenbar hier vorbeigegangen
und hat diese Krabbe ausgesucht. Sehr schön.
Also man muss
bloß so ein bisschen
ein Kristallisationskeim für solche Sachen
irgendwo hingehen, bei mir war das, dass ich diese
Poster hingelegt habe und es
passiert einfach von alleine und wir können von hier aus
von unserem Podcast-Tisch so ein bisschen zugucken,
wie da Leute sitzen. Ja, so acht Leute ungefähr.
Und Spaß haben. Ja, also das mischt sich natürlich auch.
Nebenan sind Django-Leute
und ein paar Leute von einem Hackerspace
aus Leipzig. Das mischt sich auch mal,
aber es sind auch
schon einige Leute aus der Rust-Community
da gewesen, die nicht noch von anderen Veranstaltungen
kannten. Was wir leider verpasst haben,
ist eine Swift-Assembly-Anwenden.
Das wäre was für nichts.
Obwohl ich mir nicht sicher bin, ob die nicht vielleicht unorganisiert
sogar existiert in der großen
Assembly-Raum irgendwo. Es ist schon mal schauen.
paar Leute mit Zwift-T-Shirts.
Ich habe heute irgendwie zufällige Zwift-Shirts.
Also ich glaube, ihr müsstet hier einfach bloß irgendwo noch
einen Marker setzen und sagen, übrigens, jetzt gibt es
ein Zwift-Assembly und dann kommen auch 10.000 Leute da.
Lieber drei Sticker auf dem Tisch, dann passt das.
Zweiter Tag, lass machen.
Nehmen wir einfach den Tisch jetzt hier.
Ein schöner Mikrofon.
Wir kriegen ans T-Shirt eine Fahne,
hängen die hin.
Der Tisch ist das.
Also was ich mir jetzt sagen wollte, was das Schöne
an diesen Assemblies ist, dass das irgendwie von alleine
funktioniert und dass sich da Leute treffen.
Das ist so ein bisschen so ein Klassentreffen.
Man trifft dann plötzlich Leute her, die man nur aus dem Internet kennt.
Das ist ja doch so, was ich an Konferenzen allgemein liebe.
Redet man mit jemandem, dann zeigt der einem seinen GitHub-Account und du stellst fest,
ach Mensch, ich kenne dich und ich habe auch deinen Code schon gelesen und wir haben über das und das schon geschrieben.
Das ist eigentlich das, was am Kongress das Geilste ist.
Auf jeden Fall.
Dass man die Leute endlich mal in real life trifft.
Das stimmt, ja.
Ich hätte noch einen Talk, den ich gestern Abend noch gesehen habe.
Es gibt so eine Serie an Talks mittlerweile über die Jahre hinweg von Michael Steyl.
Die fangen immer an mit The Ultimate, dann ein Keyword und dann Talk.
Und dieses Jahr war es The Ultimate.
Das Keyword ist immer irgendeine Art von Computer.
Genau, irgendeine Legacy-Hardware, Computer-Hardware.
Und letztes Jahr war das der Nintendo.
Dieses Jahr war das der Apollo Guidance-Computer.
Das war irgendwie ein anderthalb Stunden Talk.
Das ist schon wie ein Gaming System.
Die haben, glaube ich, mehrere Rekorde gebrochen.
Ich habe letztes Jahr mir gesagt,
eine krassere Keynote-Präsentation aufwendiger geht nicht mehr.
Ich bin eines Besseren belehrt worden gestern.
Wir packen den Ultimate Game Boy Talk in die Show.
Ja, absolut.
Sowohl der von letztem Jahr, als auch alle anderen davor von ihm
und auch der von diesem Jahr absolut abgefahren.
Also ich dachte mir immer, der hat sich bestimmt drei Jahre damit beschäftigt
und ist dann irgendwann mal zum Kongress gegangen und hat das irgendwann mal vorgestellt.
Aber der hat halt im nächsten Jahr über das nächste Gerät geredet
und dieses Jahr hält er schon wieder einen Vorteil.
Und das ist vor allem, also Kilian, du musst den lieben mit seinen Vorträgen, oder?
Weil da brauchst du nicht, da musst du dich auf Zweifachgeschwindigkeit stellen.
Bei dem müsstest du wahrscheinlich sogar du, um entspannt mitzuhören, irgendwie...
Nee, bei Videos kann ich das nicht, nur bei Audioinhalten.
Ein Video ist doch lustig, weil wenn dir die Stimme so nach oben geht,
langsam den Pitch mit korrigieren, genau.
Aber die sprechen halt in dem Talk
wirklich einfach zweifache Geschwindigkeit.
Das sind beide Deutsche,
sprechen aber auf Englisch in einer unheimlichen Geschwindigkeit.
das ist halt wirklich harter Tobak, was sie da vortragen.
Sie erklären wirklich von der Pike auf,
wie dieser Guidance-Computer funktioniert
mit allen möglichen Registern und
Opcodes und Assembly
und dem ganzen Kram und du sitzt dann da und
merkst du, wie es so an dir vorbei
weht. Also das ist schon was, was
man nachvollziehen kann, oder? Ja, schon.
Das ist ein Legisystem, weil sie es komplett erklären
können. Also ich klettverstehe. Ich fand das letztes Jahr
richtig geil bei diesem Ultimate Gameboy-Vortrag, weil sie
wirklich Texturen gezeigt haben von alten Spielen.
Ach, Gameboy, ich nenne du. Genau. Gameboy, klar.
Dann haben sie erklärt, wie diese Sidescroller funktionieren,
wie unterschiedlich, also wie jetzt so ein Super Mario
funktioniert, dann wird dann darauf hingewiesen, ach übrigens,
die Wolken und die Büsche sind die gleiche Textur.
Und dann denkst du dir so, ah.
Und der große Mario ist eigentlich ein Hack, weil es geht
eigentlich, so viel passt eigentlich gar nicht in der Teil rein.
Ich würde gerade sagen, die Spiele
früher waren ja alle irgendwie Hacks, weil die Hardschwerden
auch so schlecht waren. Und sie haben auch ganz andere Sachen erklärt.
Was sie mich am meisten geflasht haben, ist, wie
diese Rennspiele auf diesen
Geräten funktioniert haben, wie sie es gemacht haben,
dass die Straße sich so in die Kurve biegt,
perspektivisch. Das habe ich mir vorher
gedacht, wie kann man das machen? Das haben sie extrem
anschaulich, ich möchte das jetzt nicht vorausnehmen,
ich kann es auch gar nicht noch mal erklären,
aber das haben sie extrem anschaulich
in dem Talk erklärt und das ist also
wirklich empfiehend.
Ihr zeigt auf mich, ja?
Ich neige immer dazu,
Leute zu unterbrechen und dann das Thema
weiterzuerzählen.
Ich wollte einfach nur
auf diesen Talk hinweisen, weil der ist
einfach, zum einen, weil
du es gestern nicht mehr geschafft hast, Kilian,
weil das einfach von der
Geschwindigkeit dein Talk ist,
so wie ich deine
Podcast-Hör-
kennen.
Und weil das, also das ist jedes Mal
für mich der absolute, also
einer der absoluten Höhepunkte dieser Talk, weil
du sitzt dort, bist einfach nur absolut geflasht
und
bist danach
um einiges klüger
und hast
aber trotzdem
70% des Inhalts nicht wirklich verstanden.
Ja, man sagt ja auch immer, was das Schönste ist. Also es gibt
auf dem Kongress immer die zwei Arten von Leute,
die zum ersten Mal da sind und quasi alle Talks
anschauen und die, die danach wiederkommen
und die Talks erstmal beiseite lassen und sich
die Community drumherum geben und die Talks
lieber in dem Video-Module anschauen, aber es gibt
manche Talks, die will man einfach auch live gesehen haben.
Die sind wirklich so fantastisch, da will man
Teil der Atmosphäre sein und
die miterlebt haben quasi.
Ich hatte auch noch einen richtig guten
Talk von gestern und zwar
von Vincent Hoppacz. Ich weiß nicht, ob er
die letzten, also ich habe zumindest bisher schon
zwei Talks von ihm gesehen, von vorherigen Kongressen. Das eine
war über Xerox-Drucker,
wo so richtig krasse Fehler mitgezeigt
und das andere war letztes Jahr über N26,
wo er gezeigt hat, dass die... Ach, Xerox war auch
sein Ding, das wusste ich gar nicht mehr. Ah, sehr cool.
Und gestern ging es um die
fabelhafte Welt des Online-Bakings, war
ging nicht mehr um, oder ging gar nicht mehr um
N26, sondern es ging eher darum,
dass so eine
Finanz-Apps, irgendwie so 31 Stück
und davon irgendwie 20 aus Deutschland oder so,
ich weiß die genauer zahlen gar nicht mehr, die nutzen
so ein Sicherheits-Framework,
was er dann gezeigt hat, wie man es
aushebeln kann, potenziell. Ich glaube, das Ganze, so wie er es
gezeigt hat, funktioniert so nur auf Android, auf iOS,
ist das so nicht möglich. Aber trotzdem
haben sie es einfach, glaube ich, noch nicht ausprobiert.
Naja, potenziell ist es das gleiche.
Also es ist halt ein Framework, was dynamisch
reingelinkt wird und er hat das quasi ausgetauscht und damit
konnte er das dann komplett aushebeln. Aber ich glaube,
dass das so bei iOS nicht geht, weil es im Bundle drin ist.
Geht halt nur mit J-Breck. Mit J-Breck geht es, stimmt.
Aber wenn du ein J-Breck hast, bist du auch sehr doof.
Ja, genau.
Das hat auch, glaube ich, auf Android nur funktioniert, wenn du
ein geroutetes Telefon hast. Ja, es muss
geroutet sein und dann musst du auch nochmal so eine App
runterladen, die das Austausch dann quasi macht.
Und dann ist es aber weg
quasi beim TAN-Verfahren
etwas absegnest, wo der Betrag aber gar nicht stimmt.
Und für dich sieht es die ganze Zeit so aus, als würdest du jetzt diesen Betrag
absegnen, aber eigentlich ist es ein ganz anderer Betrag,
der überwiesen wird und können ja theoretisch auch andere Dinge
ausgetauscht werden. Die Moral von der Geschichte war,
Zwei-Faktor-Authentifikation ist keine
Zwei-Faktor-Authentifikation, wenn beide Faktoren
auf einem Gerät stattfinden.
Die Besparkasse, hör mal bitte zu.
Richtig.
Es gibt allerdings auch mitunter sehr bedrückende
Talks, wenn Hacker
darüber berichten, wie es in
anderen Ländern zugeht oder wie zum Beispiel die
Überwachungssysteme oder die Regierung
von anderen Ländern oder von
unserem Land die Bevölkerung
überwacht und ein
Vortrag, der gestern lief, war
wieder
eines dieser Beispiele, der hieß nämlich
Game Fight Control,
das klingt erstmal ein bisschen spaßig,
der war von Katika Kühnreich
und sie ist, ich habe
nicht mehr ganz auf dem Schirm, was
sie ist, sie ist glaube ich
Politologin oder sowas an der
und hat einen Vortrag gehalten über das Social Scoring System,
das in China gerade eingeführt wird.
Und das hat sich ziemlich gut damit auseinandergesetzt,
wer das implementiert und was das für Konsequenzen hat.
Und zwar geht es dabei darum, dass das chinesische Unternehmen,
es gibt drei sehr große,
die fast den gesamten chinesischen Internetmarkt unter sich aufteilen,
anfangen, Techniken aus der Spieleentwicklung
in unterschiedlichen Bereichen des Lebens einzusetzen.
Das liegt auch daran, also einer von denen ist Tencent,
der ja auch bei Blizzard und einigen anderen Spielefirmen dabei ist.
Genau, das worüber sie geredet hat, war das System von Alibaba
und das ist allerdings fast identisch.
Und zwar geht es beim Social Scoring darum,
dass jeder Bürger quasi ein Punktekonto hat
und das gemeinsame Miteinanderleben wie ein Spiel ist
und du positive Punkte oder einen positiven Score dafür kriegst,
wenn du einen möglichst,
wie sagt man das auf Deutsch,
complicit, wenn du einen möglichst
ordentliches
Regimetreu.
Nennen wir es Regimetreu oder
Regimetreu-Punkte.
Starke Stemplekarte.
Das wird unser Thema übrigens.
Man kann sich das auch sehr anschaulich
geben, indem man sich einfach
Black Mirror Staffel 3 Folge 1 anschaut.
Das ist ungefähr genau das.
Im Endeffekt ist es so, egal was du machst, du kriegst dafür dann entweder positive
oder negative Punkte und wenn du Leute kennst,
einen negativen Score haben, dann zieht das deinen Score auch mit runter.
Was dann natürlich so Implikationen hat, dass du dir aussuchst,
mit wem du redest und dass das deinen Freundeskreis vielleicht beeinflusst
und dass Leute geoutet werden oder geoustet werden,
die regimekritisch sind.
Aber das fängt erst mit kleinen Sachen an,
dass du vielleicht ein bisschen schneller irgendwie an irgendwelche Dienste rankommst
oder vielleicht mal erste Klasse fliegen darfst.
Und es ist allerdings wirklich vorgesehen, ab 2020 das mandatory zu machen,
dass jeder chinesische Bürger so einen Score hat
und dann quasi dieses Incentive-Programm reingezwungen wird.
Du bist gerade ein bisschen fast drüber hinweggegangen,
habe ich das Gefühl.
Das Wichtige ist halt vor allem,
dass du deine Score nicht nur für dich zählst,
sondern dass dein Freundeskreis gerade mit reinzählt.
Und wenn du Freunde hast mit einem niedrigen Score,
dass das auch deine Score eben beeinflusst.
Und somit bist du quasi, wenn du dieses System nutzt,
Incentive-Weist deinen Freundeskreis aufzuräumen
und die Leute mit niedrigen Scores,
die halt sagen wir mal jetzt nicht regimetreu sind,
da rauszuschmeißen und den Leuten halt auch keine Plattform gibst,
kein Ohr schenkst und diese Ideen, die die
haben könnten, gar nicht weitertragt und
dein Hirn einen ganz großen
Vorstudien fixieren lässt. Oder auf sie einredest.
Also in der DDR war es so,
dass man die Leute dazu
als inoffizielle Mitarbeiter
geworben hat und sie sich gegenseitig ausspioniert
haben und dann waren die Mittel des Regimes,
dich in den Klass zu stecken oder dich nicht
deinen Arbeitsplatz aussuchen zu lassen
oder dass deine Kinder nicht auf die richtige Schule kommen.
Und so bekommst du einfach keinen Kredit mehr,
kannst dem bloß nach Economy fliegen. Genau, die machen
Es ist einfach genau andersrum. Statt Peitsche die Zuckerrübe.
Und das wurde auch in dem Extra-Credity, was sie gezeigt hat,
auch mal kurz mit erzählt, das fand ich einfach ein wunderschönes, anschauliches Beispiel.
Ja, wunderschön.
Dass Blizzard das am Anfang mal mit World of Warcraft hatte,
dass dein Charakter irgendwie irgendwelche Mali bekommen hat.
Also irgendwie wurdest du dafür bestraft,
wenn du dich nicht jeden Tag angemeldet hast.
Und das fand die Community absolut scheiße und hat dagegen rebelliert.
Es ging darum, dass du schlafen sollst.
Ja, aber das war halt, wenn du dich nicht jeden Tag angemeldet hast,
wurdest du bestraft als Charakter erstmal dafür.
In der Richtung.
Und dann haben Blizzard das eben genau umgedreht,
als die Community sich aufgeregt
Nämlich haben sie dann nicht mehr dich bestraft dafür, wenn du dich nicht angemeldet hast, sondern die haben dich belohnt dafür, wenn du dich jeden Tag angemeldet hast.
Und plötzlich, es ist genau dieselbe Scheißidee.
Und plötzlich fand die Community das klasse und jeder so, ja, funktioniert wunderbar, aber es ist doch dieselbe Kackidee wie vorher.
Die negative Zahlen, jetzt positiv.
Ja genau, genau das ist es eben.
Sie bestrafen dich nicht mehr, sie belohnen dich für die andere Seite.
Und genau das ist das, was das Social-Score-System macht.
Sie machen das nicht für die DDR, die sich bestraft dafür, ein nicht guter Bürger zu sein, sondern sie belohnen dich dafür, ein möglichst guter Bürger zu sein.
und das spielt halt alles an, was Menschen ausmacht.
Du kannst uns richtig damit
verarschen und ausnutzen.
Aber das ist ja eigentlich keine Kackidee, sondern eigentlich
eine super geniale Idee für das Regime.
Ja, prinzipiell schon.
In dem Fall war die Idee von Blizzard super.
Es ist extrem clever.
Und es ist überraschend, das fand ich jetzt im Kontext
zum Kongress und vor allem von dem
ersten Tag interessant, es kommt
eine Menge Parallelen
zu einem Vortrag,
einem zweiten Vortrag, also es war eigentlich eher eine Lesung
mit dem Titel Quality Land
und es war eine Live-Lesung
von Marc-Uwe Kling, den kennt vielleicht die ein oder andere
vom Känguru-Manufest.
Das ist der, der mit dem Känguru zusammenlebt.
Da war ich am Anfang so ein bisschen skeptisch, weil ich dachte,
der stellt jetzt hier sein Buch vor, passt das überhaupt?
Geht das nicht ein bisschen in die falsche Richtung,
dass die Leute jetzt hier anfangen, ihre Bücher vorzustellen?
Aber es war gut.
Es ist im Prinzip eine extrem cool gemachte,
mit dem Humor von Marc-Uwe Kling
geschriebene Dystopie
von Deutschland in
100 Jahren. Und es ist ja eine Tech-Dystopie.
Insofern passt es. Also ist jetzt nicht,
hätte er jetzt dort als Känguru-Valgetragen,
würde man sagen, ja, wir haben gerade davor gesprochen,
dass die Chinesen quasi genau das eingeführt haben.
Das ist keine Dystopie mehr. Das ist quasi real.
Er hat in dem Vortrag gesagt,
ja, übrigens, das, was die Chinesen da, der hatte sich den Vortrag
vorher, über den wir gerade gerettet haben, auch angehört
und er hat gemeint, die haben das von mir geklaut.
Sorry, dass ich es so geschrieben habe.
Also ich muss sagen, ich war nicht in einem Talk mit der Lesung
und das Buch gibt es ja in zwei Ausführungen.
Genau, ich wollte mir das heute früh holen.
Es gibt eine schwarze
also bevor du es bei Amazon bestellst.
Und ich habe mich gefragt, was der Unterschied ist
und dann habe ich die letzte Folge
Logbuch Netzpolitik zu Ende gehört und es geht tatsächlich darum,
es sind zwischendurch immer Werbeeinspieler,
die hat bei dem Vortrag gestern
seinen Bassist dann immer so reingesungen.
Und in der weißen, in der
hellen Fassung sind die Werbeeinspieler
utopisch und in der
dunklen Fassung sind sie dystopisch.
Ja, ich will ja beide Fassungen haben.
Sehr kacke.
Ja, und wir haben jetzt noch ein
Oder zwei weitere Tage von zwei
Tage sogar noch. Genau. Tag drei und vier und den Rest
von Tag zwei natürlich auch. Es geht heute auch eine Weile
weiter. Genau, ist ja erst acht Uhr abends.
Ja, das ist ja quasi noch vormittags hier.
Wir haben gerade Mittag gegessen.
Also, genau, Kiki und ich, wir haben schon gesagt,
wir werden wahrscheinlich hier den Kongress
heute Abend um zwei Uhr
15 ungefähr verlassen.
Ihr geht noch zum Hacker-Jeopardy. Ich kann mir das
Hacker-Jeopardy nicht ergeben lassen. Ich liebe das Hacker-Jeopardy
und ich habe fast geweint, also jetzt ist es ja
nicht existierte. Ich kann auch verstehen,
dass man diesen Orga-Aufwand nicht jedes Jahr treiben kann.
aber was eine tolle Veranstaltung
ich werde nachher meinen Spaß haben, ich gehe auf jeden Fall
Wird das eigentlich immer mit aufgezeichnet? Das wird auch aufgezeichnet
lohnt sich auch
den Aufzeichner anzuschauen auf jeden Fall, aber es lohnt sich
natürlich noch viel mehr da zu sein
ich weiß nicht ob ich teilnehmen werde, ich glaube ich werde nicht teilnehmen
und die normalen Vorträge gehen ja sowieso bis 0.30
also die letzten normalen Vorträge
und in meiner Erfahrung von gestern
fährt da dann an den
zumindest auf der Strecke die ich brauche sowieso der Nachtbus
und so von
es gibt die Lounge
und es gibt genug Leute die hier komplett durchmachen
Da können wir vielleicht auch kurz was zu sagen.
Ja, aber ich möchte noch Menschenkontakt morgen haben.
Das Ding ist ja, die Leipziger Messe,
die Leipziger Messe, wo wir gerade sind,
die ist ja relativ weit außerhalb.
Die ist ja irgendwie nördlich von Leipzig,
also quasi nicht mehr direkt Teil des Ganzen.
Und der LVB, also die Leipziger Verkehrsbetriebe,
haben eine extra Straßenbahn eingerichtet,
sodass man wirklich die ganze Nacht hier
im 10-Minuten-Tag wegfahren kann.
Also ich habe doch einen Bereich bis jetzt bloß gehört.
Habt ihr die schon benutzt?
Ja, die ist ja voll.
Zumindest die Stoßzeiten, in denen ich gefahren bin.
Und fahren die durch die ganze Stadt
oder fahren die bis zum Hauptbahnhof?
Ich fahre direkt bis zum Hauptbahnhof und da ist dann auch Institution.
Also die fährt bis zum Hauptbahnhof.
Genau.
Und da wechselt alles mit.
Und das ist aber richtig gut, weil, wie gesagt, 10 Minuten Tag, mitten in der Nacht.
Das haben die Extraler verengedischt.
Es gibt sogar ein extra Ticket für die vier Tage jetzt.
Die Leipziger müssen sich wundern, was da irgendwie nachts komischer Leichenzug.
Ich habe gestern in der S-Bahn, das war witzig, so Leute, die S-Bahn, also so voll ist die doch sonst auch nicht.
Wie steigen alle hier aus? Was ist da denn los?
Fand ich großartig.
Das hatten sie auch in der Freakshow, wie wir gesagt, dass die erstmal mit den Leuten reden mussten
und so erstmal kurz erklären mussten,
sich eigentlich eingelassen haben.
Sie hatten Ihnen die
Wi-Fi-Access-Zahlen
gezeigt. War das nicht so,
weil ich mich erinnere? Sie haben Ihnen gezeigt, wie viele
Geräte um verschiedene
Uhrzeiten auf dem Kongress
bisher immer so verbunden waren.
Um einfach zu zeigen, hey,
also bei uns ist halt hier um 12 Uhr nicht Schluss,
sondern da fängt es ja so richtig an.
Ihr wollt wirklich
rund um die Uhr auch komplett nachts.
Also es gibt irgendwie
die erste Bahn fährt irgendwie eine
5 Stunden nach der letzten Bahn oder sowas wieder.
De facto gibt es keine
Nachtpause.
Sehr immens, dieser Aufwand.
Ja, finde ich großartig.
Es gab auch die letzten Jahre,
ich weiß nicht, wie das ist, dieses Jahr in Leipzig, aber es gab
die Deutschen Bahn auch extra Züge,
die zum Kongress fahren, die organisiert werden.
Das ist total toll.
Man merkt einfach, dass es seit 30 Jahren
eine Institution ist in Deutschland
und dass die Leute auch gerne
mitmachen bei sowas. Ich folge
jetzt seit kurzem den Twitter-Account der Leipziger Messe
und da sind auch schon einige
lustige Kommentare
rübergekommen und die reagieren nach positiv
drauf. Auf der anderen Seite, die Leute, die den Twitter-Account
betreuen, sind wahrscheinlich auch irgendwelche Social-Media-Angestellten,
die eher mit dem
Club positiv verbunden sind.
Am Tag 0 liefen
zwei Mitarbeiter von, also
die schienen relativ hoch hier so
bei der Leipziger Messe irgendwie
zu arbeiten, die liefen hier so
durch die Glashalle und über das ganze Gelände
und haben sich das Ganze ganz interessiert angeschaut und
da hast du auch so gemerkt,
aha,
ach ja, interessant.
Ich musste den gleichen Weg laufen,
davon bin ich da einfach mitgelaufen.
Seht ihr jetzt auch?
Ja, da hätte ich...
Das wäre lustiger.
Sieht ja auch mal ganz anders aus.
Ja, genau.
Aber da wäre ich gerne mal so Flieger an der Wand
in ihrem Gedankengang gewesen.
Die Leute vom CCH in Hamburg
haben sich mittlerweile schon ein bisschen gut an den Kongress gewöhnt.
Ich habe auch gehört, ein paar Leute vom CCH sind wohl auch mit hier,
weil die auch Kongress-Teilnehmer geworden sind über die Jahre.
Die müssen den Leuten vom CCL hier mal zeigen.
Das sind toll, Leute.
Die wissen, was sie machen.
Für so ein Kongresszentrum ist das was relativ Großes.
Aber für so eine Leipziger Messe ist so eine Veranstaltung
mit 15.000 Leuten eigentlich relativ klein.
Wenn man bedenkt, dass hier bis vor ein paar Jahren
die Gamescom waren und die Leipziger Buchmesse
ist ja auch relativ groß.
Und die Automessen, die hier stattfinden,
sind eigentlich auch ziemlich gut besucht.
Da sind mehrere 100.000 Leute am Tag.
Da ist noch Platz zum Wachsen.
Da ist noch ein bisschen Kapazität.
100.000 Kongress-Teileber vor.
Also es ist nicht ganz wie bei der Gamescom,
hast du überall Stände, wo du durchgehen kannst,
sondern sind Millionen Menschen da auf einem Platz.
Das ist ja nicht ganz so der Fall.
Also diese Vortragssäle, die sind halt irgendwann voll
und du kannst sie auch nicht größer machen bei deiner Akustik und alles kaputt geht.
Also hier ist die Semantik allgemein ein bisschen anders.
Also bei einer Messe ist es allgemein nicht so,
dass plötzlich alle Leute aus einem Saal raus müssen
und in einen anderen Saal reingehen,
dass sich so ein Saal auf einmal komplett leert.
Das hast du hier schon an einigen Stellen gemerkt,
dass es doch dann knarzt und dass es dann so ein bisschen Stau gibt.
Gerade wenn die Leute rausgehen aus dem Saal.
Das war der Fahrplan relativ eng.
Das habe ich gestern gemerkt bei dem PC-Wahlhack.
Da habe ich wie gesagt angestanden.
Ich stand noch relativ weit vorne.
Vor mir war so, keine Ahnung, 100-Peter-Stange.
Aber da fing ich glaube ich auch erst 10 Minuten später an.
Und dann sind auch nicht alle reingekommen.
Also es war schon schwierig, weil man warten musste.
Ich habe mich heute im Saal vertan.
Und war leider in der Diagonalen im falschen Saal.
Und boah, das war ein Weg.
Erst lange anstehen, dann im falschen Saal ankommen.
Und dann wieder rüberlaufen und noch mal.
Hat sich leider von euch eigentlich ein T-Shirt geholt?
Ich will immer noch, aber ich glaube nicht, dass es jetzt noch viel geht.
Ich war heute kurz dazu verleitet, mal diese Schlange zu fotografieren.
Das muss man natürlich nicht machen.
Aber das ging einmal über den gesamten Vorhof der Leipziger Messe.
Das war bestimmt eine 120 Meter lange Schlange.
Ich war kurz schockiert, als ich heute früh ankam.
So lang war die Schlange für die Tagestickets doch auch noch nicht bisher.
Das war immens.
Du gehst doch rein irgendwann.
Das ist die Mördschlange.
Genau.
Bitte was?
Also jetzt habe ich die Wahl entweder T-Shirt haben wollen
und meine Erkältung richtig hart verkacken
oder langsam genesen hoffentlich und keinen T-Shirt haben.
Genau, die standen vor allem alle draußen.
Ja, draußen, wo man auch die Späterjacke anzieht.
Vielleicht geht es dann auch besser.
Das ist sowieso einer der weiteren Gründe für jeden, der überlegt,
hey, das klingt alles so cool, da muss ich auch mal hin.
Es gibt Merch.
Am Tag Null anreisen hat den weiteren Vorteil,
dass man dann irgendwann im Laufe des Abends die Kasse geöffnet
und man kann sich schon sein Bändchen holen.
Denn am Tag 1, am Anfang, vor der Keynote, anstehen, macht keinen Spaß.
Es scheint aber gegangen zu sein.
Es standen echt viele Leute da, aber das war auch
sehr, sehr effizient. Also die sind ganz gut durchgekommen.
Von Tag 0 war die Schlange fast länger,
habe ich das Gefühl. Es ist sehr effizient, vor allem, weil halt auch
einfach der
CCC selber die Technik macht bei einer Kasse.
Also die haben ja eigenes Kassensystem, was sie da machen.
Aber es ist halt trotzdem noch,
also wenn halt irgendwie 13.000, 15.000 Leute,
das ist natürlich nicht alle auf einmal,
aber ein großer Teil davon
alle zum gleichen Zeitpunkt
zur gleichen Keynote wollen und rein wollen,
dann ist das am Tag vorher einfach sehr
entspannt. Also wie lange standen wir
am Tag vorher? Es war schon eine lange
Schlange, aber wir hatten 10 Minuten.
Ungelogen 10 Minuten. Das finde ich absolut machbar.
Das ging so flüssig durch.
Wunderschön. Wie effizient das läuft.
Handy-Inhalten-Scans. Oh, da ist schon mein Bändchen.
Ja genau, Handy-Inhalten, QR-Code-Scan,
Bändchen. Ich habe da sogar noch
mein Public Transport-Ticket dort gekauft
für 16,50 Euro. Ich habe einen 50-Euro-Schein bezahlt.
Das dauert ja normalerweise bei so einer Supermarktkasse
auch ewig, aber selbst das geht es in die Läufe.
Hast du ein Bitcoin zurückgekriegt?
Ich glaube, dass du ein Bitcoin
zu zahlen, dann zahlst du gleich mal das Doppelte wegen der Transaktionsgebühr.
Okay, ich glaube wir sind
ich weiß gar nicht,
wie lange wir jetzt aufgenommen haben, aber wir sind von der
Zeit ganz gut dabei.
Das steht dann ja, wie es weitergeht.
Also laut Sendeplan
könnten wir eventuell noch 10 Minuten reden, aber
habt ihr noch irgendwas, was ihr
was bei euch noch so auf der
To-Do-Liste steht?
Jetzt jenseits von konkreten Talks vielleicht
und auch generell, also
nicht jetzt ausgeschlossenen Talks, aber
Irgendwas, wo ihr sagt, hey, das habe ich auf jeden Fall davor.
Also ich zum Beispiel, ich habe meine Cyber-Rolle,
mein Cyber-Band, Klebeband
in gelb mit Cyber drauf.
Ich glaube, die leiche mir einfach nur nochmal von Kilian aus.
Das habe ich die letzten drei Jahre immer verkackt,
da rechtzeitig anzutanzen.
Wo gibt es die denn? Vergiss es.
Sie hatten noch eine Kiste gestern.
Wo gab es die denn? In der großen
Assembly-Halle.
Also auf meiner To-Do-Liste steht hier eigentlich nochmal
alles in Ruhe ablaufen. Ich war zwar
schon am Tag Null da und bin schon viel durch die
Gegend gelatscht und habe mir schon die Füße platt gelatscht,
aber irgendwie habe ich es noch nicht geschafft, an jeder Ecke
gewesen zu sein. Ja, würde ich gerne
kurz sowas sagen. Und zwar dieses Rumlaufen. Das ist ja ein relativ
großes Gelände und rumzulaufen dauert ja wirklich lange
und die Leute, die ja viel unterwegs sind, die laufen nicht,
die fahren. Und da fahren die auf allem Möglichen.
Also Tim Rittloff hat ja gerade seine Rolle
ja gerade abgestellt gehabt.
Das ist das Normalste.
Irgendwelche Skateboards oder so ist wahrscheinlich auch
noch ein bisschen normal. Das ist auch so ein Special-Roller.
Richtig cool sind auch irgendwelche
so selbstgebaute
keine Ahnung, wie nennt man das?
So Wartekisten. Wartekisten, ja.
Rollentutter haben. Dann hat einer einen Sessel
umgebaut. Der ist mit einem Wurzelstruck
gefahren, richtig gut. Also elektrisch sogar.
Hoverboards sind sehr viele unterwegs.
Es gab so ein
Monsterboard
irgendwie mit so
30 cm Rädern.
Irgendwie so ein
Cross-Longboard quasi.
Cross-E-Longboard mit
LED-Stripes drunter.
Die LED-Stripes, die gehören natürlich auch.
Also das gehört noch auf die To-Do-Liste für die nächsten Kongresse.
Du brauchst
Switch, Power Supply,
LED-Scheiß und irgendwas, was fährt.
Was cool ist. Ich würde mich nicht
wundern, wenn hier irgendwann so ein Hochrad vorbeifahren
würde. Oh, es sind Leute...
Es sind Leute mit
sehr obskuren Fahrrädern bereits hier unterwegs
gewesen, wo auf so ein kleines Mini-Kinderfahrrad
noch irgendwas oben drauf geschweißt war, damit
die Leute dann möglichst hoch drauf sitzen.
So ein Original-Postrad
habe ich gestern gesehen. Also richtig in gelb,
so ein uralt Postrad.
Sehr cool.
Ich werde bis auf der Bus aus der Assemblade rumfährt.
Ja.
Ja, wobei, also man muss dazu sagen,
also am Tag Null war es halt wirklich so,
ich bin ohne Rad, ohne irgendwelche Verkehrsmittel,
internes Verkehrsmittel hier.
Und am Tag Null, wo die ganzen,
also quasi die ganzen Engel schon da waren,
oder irgendwie so die Insider quasi,
da war wirklich so eine,
ich würde sagen, jeder Zweite hat einen Roller gehabt
oder Inlandsgates oder Rollstuhl oder was auch immer.
und ich dachte so, na toll.
Na toll.
Aber das geht jetzt gar nicht mehr so richtig.
Jetzt geht es ein bisschen unter.
Ja genau, jetzt geht es ein bisschen unter.
Wie wird das denn, wenn hier alle mit Roller rumfahren?
Das ist ja ein Riesenchaos.
Ich habe echt eine Weile drüber nachgedacht.
Ich habe nämlich noch ein Longboard im Kofferraum,
ob ich hier mit rumfahren sollte.
Ach, du auch.
Vielleicht holen wir es morgen einfach mal raus.
Aber ich habe so ein bisschen Schiss gehabt.
Mit dem Fahrrad kannst du relativ schnell bremsen.
Mit dem Longboard hatte ich Angst,
dass ich Leute verletze,
wenn ich irgendwelche Gegend fahre und mir plötzlich jemand vor die Nase
hoppst und mich nicht sieht. Ich glaube, am coolsten
fand ich, da waren wahrscheinlich schon mehr Rollen,
aber ich habe die immer gesehen, da hat ein Schuh
an, die hinten Rollen drin haben.
Und da kann er mit den Schuhen rumrollen und dann aber direkt
auch wieder Bremsen mit den Schuhen, wenn er vorne runter geht.
Ich habe eigentlich erwartet, dass jemand die Treppen oder sogar die Rolltreppen
irgendwie moddet, dass man da mit
Fahrbahnuntersätzen direkt hoch und runter kommt,
aber in doch nicht dergleichen gesehen.
Skatende Leute habe ich hier noch gar nicht gesehen.
Leider sehe ich viele.
Jetzt wurde es gesagt, macht das nächstes Jahr garantiert.
die man auf der Straße kennt, an irgendwelchen
Achso, du meinst die Geländer runter
Ja, genau
Es geht ums Vorwärtskommen
Du kommst schnell die Treppe runter, ohne von deinem Gefährt
absteigen zu müssen
Also ich bin mal gespannt, ob wir hier bleiben
Obwohl der nächste Kongress
2018 stattfinden wird, ob es nochmal
in Leipzig sein wird, weil dann werden die Leute, die sich
jetzt hier einmal die Zähne
ausgebissen haben, an einigen Problem, die hier vielleicht noch
auftreten, dann auf kreative Lösungen
dafür gekommen sein und vielleicht
die Rolltreppen modden, dass man da mit dem Roller runterfahren kann.
Das wurde ein GSM-Netz von Anfang an verfügbar.
Für drei von uns bietet sich das
natürlich sehr an, den Leipzig-Kongress zu haben,
als Dresdner. Wobei Berlin wäre es auch
nicht so schlimm. Nee, aber ich finde,
Hamburg ist halt um so eine Ecke von Deutschland. Leipzig ist
schön zentral. Kann man doch mal noch halten.
Dresdner ist perfekt, so recht.
Ja.
Also ich finde, eine Stunde
fahre ich mit dem ECE,
das ist auch noch okay. Super.
Das finde ich nicht viel anders. Ich glaube, so
halb Stunden des Regionalbahn. Auto auch
1,20 Stunden gefahren. Kann man
beibehalten.
Gut. Ja, Kongress ist toll.
An alle Hörer, die noch nie auf dem Kongress
waren. Kommt mal nächstes Jahr
mit unterher, dann quatschen wir mal, trinken wir mal ein Bier zusammen.
Nee, ne Mase.
Ihr wart noch nie auf dem Kongress? Seid ihr blöde?
Nein.
Mein erster Kongress ist auch noch nicht so lange zu.
Ja, also ein Unifreund von uns,
das wäre jetzt
sein erster Kongress gewesen, der hat
mich eigentlich an diese ganzen CCC-Sachen herangeführt,
weil er schon jahrelang in irgendeinem lokalen
CCC-Erfass ist.
Und er war noch nie
auf dem Kongress und wollte dieses Jahr zum allerersten
Mal auf dem Kongress und ist jetzt
krank zu Hause.
Ist aber auch echt vielleicht so Ende Dezember oder so.
Dann grüßen wir ihn doch mal.
Ja, schönen Gruß
an Gilbert. Es tut mir sehr leid, dass du gerade
nicht hier sein kannst. Ich vermisse dich sehr.
Aber vorhin im CCC-Jahresrückblick
hat er auch gefragt, wie viele der zum ersten Mal da sind
und gefühlt hat mindestens die Hälfte gehandelt.
Das ist immer so. Das ist großartig. Es gibt so viele
Neuteilnehmer jedes Mal. Das hast du halt,
wenn du exponentiell wächst.
Die kommen vor allem auch von überall her.
Die erste
Person,
jenseits von denen, mit denen ich hergekommen bin,
mit denen ich ins Gespräch kam, der kam einfach mal
aus Toronto.
Die kommen aus Dresden.
Andere Seite der Welt einfach.
Also ich komme auch definitiv wieder.
Ja, gefällt super. Ich bin auf jeden Fall dabei.
Ich werde es nächstes Mal sicher auch mal mit Engeln und keine Ahnung.
Ich bin überzeugt von der ganzen Sache.
ja, bevor ich zum ersten Mal zu einem Kongress gegangen bin,
hatte ich so ein bisschen Schiss, weil ich dachte, diese Hacker sind bestimmt
alle total düstere Menschen
und reden die ganze Zeit nur
von Zeugs, was ich eh nicht verstehe, aber es ist
eine total warme, liebevolle
und willkommen heißende
Community hier, die
einfach jeden aufnimmt, egal welchen
Entwicklungs- oder Fortschrittsgrad
hat, ob man
10 Jahre alt ist oder 70
und unglaublich viele Kinder,
also es gibt ja auch wirklich kleine
Kinder, die irgendwie
Manche überlegen jetzt vielleicht, ob sie nicht kommen können,
weil sie ihre Kinder da haben.
Also sollten schon
vielleicht vier oder fünf Jahre alt sein, aber sonst kann man
hier seine Kinder ziemlich gut beschäftigen.
Aber die haben halt nicht so viel.
Dom, wenn du das jetzt hörst, ist das wirklich keine Ausrede.
Ausrede können wir leider so
nicht mehr gelten lassen.
Nächstes Jahr musst du ran.
Es gibt ja auch eine richtige
Kinderecke.
Eine Ecke, das ist riesig.
Ja gut, eine Ecke halt von dieser Riesenhalle.
Dann gibt es
Jugendtextfarbe dabei.
Habt ihr einen Bällebad hier schon gefunden?
Ja, in der Kinderecke.
Es gibt mindestens einen Bällebad.
Das war dieses zweifarbige, oder?
War das dieses zweifarbige Bällebad?
Oder müssen wir da unbedingt nochmal hin und die Bälle sortieren?
Eben, genau.
Habt ihr die Boston Dynamic Roboter
irgendwo gesehen?
Was? Ernsthaft?
Ja, angeblich soll es sich jemand umtreten.
Ich habe sehr creepy Roboter gesehen mit Gasmasken.
Ich hoffe, der ist gut an wie Kettle.
Tim, ich bitte nicht persönlich.
Okay, habt ihr auch nicht gesehen. Da muss ich ja mal schauen.
Soll irgendwo noch sein.
Ja, dann
wrappen wir es ab, oder?
Ich habe jetzt verpasst den Snowden Talk und den Nintendo Switch Talk.
Aber das ist ja kein Problem, weil wir
wahrscheinlich heute Abend noch
die Talks von vor einigen Stunden
online haben werden.
Das Geile an der Infrastruktur ist ja,
dass die Sachen halt nicht nur online gehen,
so Ewigkeiten später, sondern fast
nachdem sie abgedreht wurden.
Also es gibt Konferenzen, die sind riesig groß,
sowas wie CppCon oder sowas,
wo die über eine ganze Woche gehen und wo
wesentlich mehr Leute hingehen, die wesentlich mehr
dafür bezahlen als hier.
Und die brauchen mehrere Monate, um ihre
Talks online zu stellen
als Video. Und hier geht das gerade was.
Wer den Talk nicht reinkommt, schaut den halt einfach auf seinem Laptop.
Machen auch viele, genau.
Die Talks live hier an so einem Assembly-Tisch gucken.
So ist das bei der Keynote ja zum Beispiel ganz regelmäßig.
Die Keynote wird meistens in
mehr oder weniger alle anderen Säle mit übertragen.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie es dieses Jahr war, weil ich
eigentlichen Zeitungen.
Und wer halt dann in die
anderen Säle auch nicht reinpasst,
zumindest war das immer so,
der kann es halt immer noch auch problemlos auf seinem Laptop
irgendwie im Heaven oder sonst wo
in der Ecke
machen, erhören,
sehen. Deswegen ist unsere Empfehlung
an euch, nachdem ihr diesen Podcast
jetzt zu Ende gehört habt,
geht auf media.ccc.de
und die Unterabteilung
34c3,
Ach, eigentlich könnt ihr ein bisschen rumbrowsen.
Ihr fangt einfach bei eins an.
So was, selten was gibt.
Ich glaube,
die Vorträge von vor 34 Jahren
gibt es nicht als Video online.
Wir schicken dir die VHS-Kassel.
Nein, öffnet eure Lieblings-Suchmaschine
und dann gibt ihr einfach...
Achso, man kann sie, glaube ich, auch als Podcast abonnieren.
Es gibt auch Podcast-Feeds.
Sind auch in allen Formaten verfügbar.
Könnt ihr auch komplett als Audio-Datei anhören.
Verschiedene Video-Formate, alles.
Qualitätsstücken, alles.
Technisch perfekt.
Genau.
Ja, dieser Podcast war auch technisch perfekt,
dank des Sendezentrums.
Wir haben ja alles gestellt bekommen,
muss man auch vielleicht mal dazu sagen.
Ja, vielen, vielen Dank.
Über das Sendezentrum haben wir nicht mehr erzählt.
Also das Sendezentrum ist direkt bei den Assembly-Tischen,
das hatten wir schon mit erzählt.
Und das ist halt ein Ort, wo man sich anmelden kann
und dann seinen Podcast hier aufnehmen
und ich glaube auch live streamen.
Also zumindest...
Also es hieß, wir sind im Stream, ich weiß zwar nicht wo,
aber wir sind zumindest am Tisch gestreamt.
Zumindest haben wir uns einfach nur am Tisch setzen müssen,
uns diese Headsets aufgesetzt und los ging es.
Das ist einfach mal ein großes Lob
an die Leute vom Sendezentrum wert und vielen,
vielen lieben Dank. Leider hat der Engel, der bei uns jetzt
hier die Tontechnik
überwacht, leider jetzt gerade seinen Kopf aber nicht.
Das heißt, er hat uns gerade.
Wir geben ihm einfach gleich ein Bier aus.
Oder eine Mate.
Gut, dann auch euch vielen Dank
fürs Zuhören. Ich denke, wir sind soweit durch.
Genau, das war...
Hört mal alle Hallo Swift, weil...
Das war Hallo Swift und...
Akronomisierbar.
Vielen Dank, dass ihr zugehört habt.
Und der nächste Podcast in eurem Feed
beginnt in 3,
2, 1.